Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Let the soldiers know that now is the hour when in their hands rests the fate of the entire motherland. Either Russia will fall or she will be reborn. My soldiers, you are not armed and drawn up to fight for Peter. You fight for the nation entrusted to Peter by birth, for your kin, for the people of all Russia, the land that has protected you, the land that now awaits the decision of fortune. Remember as you fight that God and truth are on our side. And remember how many times the Lord of Battles
感谢您收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。让士兵们知道，现在正是整个祖国的命运掌握在他们手中的时刻。要么俄罗斯陷落，要么她将浴火重生。我的士兵们，你们拿起武器不是为了皮特而战，你们是为了生来就托付给皮特的国家而战，为了你们的亲人，为了全俄罗斯的人民，这片曾经保护过你们、如今正等待命运裁决的土地。在战斗时请记住，上帝与真理在我们这一边。并且记住，战神曾有多少次
has shown us his favour. And know this of me, of Peter, that on my life I set no value, as long as Russia may live in piety, in prosperity, and in glory. There we have, in ringing masculine tones, the proclamation of Peter the Great, Tsar and autocrat of all the Russia's to his troops on the 26th of June 1709, the eve of the famous and seismically influential Battle of Poltava, the showdown that decided the Great Northern War. Dominic, quite possibly your favorite war I think. I love the Great Northern War. It genuinely is a great war. It is a great war isn't it? Yeah. It's very northern and it's a war. Yeah. It ticks every box. It ticks every box going. And the reason it's a great war is that it marks the kind of definitive emergence
向我们展现了他的恩宠。请了解我，了解皮特，我视自己的生命如无物，只要俄罗斯能够虔诚、繁荣、荣耀地活下去。这就是彼得大帝以激昂雄浑的语调，在1709年6月26日对他的军队发表的宣言。那是著名的、具有深远影响的波尔塔瓦战役前夕，这场决战决定了大北方战争的胜负。多米尼克，这很可能是你最喜欢的战争吧。我喜欢大北方战争。它确实是一场伟大的战争。它确实是一场伟大的战争，不是吗？是的。它非常具有北方特色，而且它是一场战争。是的。它满足了所有的条件。它满足了所有的条件。而它之所以是一场伟大的战争，是因为它标志着
of Russia as the superpower that it will be from that point on. Yeah. Uh, and unsurprisingly that speech, which I think, um, my deep masculine tone conveyed a sense of Peter as a titanic figure, not just historically, but physically. I mean, I hope people got that sense. But it's a speech that is obviously quite popular with the current leadership in Russia, isn't it? Because it's seen as a kind of great call to arms to people to die for Russia. Exactly. Exactly. And they actually read this speech or they often recite it to recruits in the Russian army
俄罗斯正式崛起为从那以后一直延续的超级大国。是的。呃，不出所料，那段演讲——我想，呃，我低沉雄浑的语调传达出了彼得作为一个不仅在历史上、而且在体型上都如泰坦般宏伟的人物形象。我的意思是，我希望听众能有这种感觉。但显然，这段演讲在俄罗斯现领导层中非常受欢迎，不是吗？因为它被视为号召人们为俄罗斯牺牲的伟大集结号。正是如此。正是如此。他们实际上会阅读这段演讲，或者经常在俄罗斯军队的新兵中背诵它。
So even today it kind of has a political resonance I guess and Vladimir Putin has compared himself with Peter the Great He has compared the war in Ukraine with the Great Northern War and the Great Northern War fought against Sweden Yeah, Swedes currently are kind of issuing all kinds of slightly nervous calls to arms, aren't they? Yes kinds of slightly nervous calls to arms, aren't they? Yes. Not surprising. Although the interesting thing, of course, the Great Northern War, lots of people won't know this, is that the Swedes were the overdogs and Russia the underdogs in the Great Northern
所以即使在今天，它也有某种政治共鸣，我想弗拉基米尔·普京曾把自己比作彼得大帝。他把乌克兰战争比作大北方战争，而大北方战争是对抗瑞典的战争。是的，瑞典人最近正在发出各种略显紧张的战斗号召，不是吗？是的，发出各种略显紧张的战斗号召，不是吗？是的。这并不令人意外。当然，有趣的是，很多人不知道大北方战争的一点是，在战争中瑞典人是大热门，而俄罗斯人是大冷门。
War, which seems completely bonkers. Well, because this is a story not just about Peter the Great, but about his great rival Charles the 12th, one of the most, I mean, intriguing military figures of his age. But it's also about so much more, isn't it? Because the story of Peter the Great, I mean, it's mad in so many ways. It's one of those historical stories. We don't get them that often, but it genuinely is one of those historical stories that a fantasy novelist would hesitate to invent it. So to give people a sense of the suite before we get into the details, Peter became Tsar of Russia when he was 10.
大北方战争，这看起来完全疯了。嗯，因为这不仅是一个关于彼得大帝的故事，也是一个关于他伟大的对手查理十二世的故事，查理十二世是他那个时代最引人入胜的军事人物之一。但它不仅于此，不是吗？因为彼得大帝的故事，我的意思是，它在许多方面都极其疯狂。它是那种我们不常遇到、但确实属于奇幻小说家都不敢轻易杜撰的历史故事。因此，在进入细节之前，为了让大家对当时的情况有个概念，彼得在10岁时就成为了俄罗斯沙皇。
His early life was scarred by the most horrific violence. There was a struggle for power with his own sister. Then he got power. Then he did a mad thing. He went into disguise on a gap year to Western Europe, where he worked in the shipyards in Amsterdam and hung around with bishops and stuff in London and in Oxford. And of course, famously had wheelbarrow races in Deptford, which is one of our favourite topics on the rest of history. I think we've covered it about six times already. We're
他的早年生活饱受最可怕暴力的摧残。他曾与自己的亲姐姐争夺权力。接着他掌握了权力。然后他做了一件疯狂的事。他在间隔年里乔装打扮前往西欧，在阿姆斯特丹的造船厂工作，还在伦敦和牛津与主教们厮混。当然，还有著名的在德普特推独轮车比赛，这是我们在《历史的余烬》中最喜欢的话题之一。我想我们大概已经报道过六次了。我们
going to do it again in the series. We're never in as much detail as we're going to do it this time. And then he comes back, he cuts everybody's beards off. He fights this colossal war against the Swedes. He found St. Petersburg. He fights the Ottoman Empire. He tortures his own son to death. And after all this, he dies peacefully in his bed, but he becomes the embodiment of Russia's aspiration to join the top table of the world's powers and to rank alongside the nations of Western Europe. So Peter has become this enduring symbol of the kind of the struggle for Russia's soul caught between East and West, Europe and Asia.
在这个系列中还会再次提到它。而且绝不会像我们这次讲得这么详细。然后他回来了，他剪掉了所有人的胡子。他与瑞典人展开了一场惊天动地的大战。他建立了圣彼得堡。他与奥斯曼帝国交战。他把自己的亲生儿子拷打至死。在经历了这一切之后，他在自己的床上安详离世，但他却成为了俄罗斯渴望加入世界顶级强国行列、并与西欧国家并肩作战这一愿望的化身。因此，彼得成为了俄罗斯灵魂挣扎的永恒象征，夹在东西方、欧洲与亚洲之间。
But as you said, it's not just about Russia. So it's about Poland, it's about Sweden, it's about the Ottoman Empire. It's sort of- And it's about Western Europe as well, isn't it? As it's rising to kind of global power and wealth. Yeah. It's like a late 17th, early 18th century version of Risk with a strong element of Game of Thrones and a strong element of succession all kind of mixed together.
但正如你所说，这不仅仅关于俄罗斯。它还关于波兰、瑞典、奥斯曼帝国。它有点——而且它也关于西欧，不是吗？随着它崛起为全球权力和财富的中心。是的。它就像是17世纪末18世纪初版本的《风险棋》，其中强力融合了《权力的游戏》和《继承之战》的元素。
Well, I think there's a much more obvious television drama that is drawing on the life of Peter the Great. And that is a drama called The Great, which was actually about Catherine the Great. And that is a drama called The Great, which was actually about Catherine the Great. And it features Peter's grandson, who historically was a bit of a cipher and gets bumped off very quickly. But I think that the producers of that series were massively influenced by the example of Peter the Great. And I think that Peter the Third in that series is Peter the Great. And there's a lot of cavorting with dwarfs, with he has kind of cohorts of pals
嗯，我认为有一部更明显的电视剧正在借鉴彼得大帝的生平。那就是一部名为《凯瑟琳大帝》的剧集，实际上讲的是凯瑟琳大帝的故事。那是另一部名为《凯瑟琳大帝》的剧集，实际上讲的是凯瑟琳大帝的故事。剧中出现了彼得的孙子，他在历史上有点像个无名小卒，而且很快就被做掉了。但我认为该剧的制作人深受彼得大帝的事迹影响。而且我认为那部剧中的彼得三世就是彼得大帝。里面有很多与侏儒嬉戏的场景，他有一群帮派伙伴
who are getting up to all kinds of unspeakable business. And he's always going, has our voice, Nicholas Holt. There's gonna be an awful lot of that in this series, it's fair to say. All right, well, let's get into the man himself. So Peter's born in Moscow at one o'clock in the morning on the 30th of May, 1672. And he is the son of the second Romanov czar, Alexis,
他们会做出各种说不出口的勾当。而且他总是用尼古拉斯·霍尔特的声音说，我们的声音怎么了。可以公平地说，这个系列里会有大量这样的情节。好吧，让我们深入了解这个人本身。彼得于1672年5月30日凌晨一点出生在莫斯科。他是罗曼诺夫王朝第二位沙皇阿列克谢的儿子，
and his wife, Natalia Nareshkina. And Peter's defining physical characteristic is that he's incredibly tall and he was a very big baby. And we actually know exactly how big, because what they would do is they would kind of paint an exact reproduction of the baby Lifesize on a board with an image of st Peter on it so you can kind of measure this image and you know exactly how big the baby Peter the great was and
他的母亲是娜塔莉亚·纳雷什基娜。彼得最显著的身体特征是他高得不可思议，而且他生下来就是一个非常大的婴儿。我们其实确切地知道他有多大，因为当时的做法是，他们会在一块木板上按婴儿的实际大小画出他的精准画像，并在旁边画上圣彼得的形象，所以你可以测量这幅画像，从而确切知道婴儿彼得大帝有多大，而且
There's all kind of bells ringing in in Moscow. There's cannons firing to celebrate the arrival of the of the Tsar's son So Moscow is also a kind of character in this story. So Moscow is at this point, what it's a few centuries old, it was founded in the late 12th century. What had happened is that the Mongols had swept over what is now Russia and amid the chaos,
莫斯科到处都是钟声齐鸣。大炮鸣响，庆祝沙皇得子。所以莫斯科也是这个故事中的一个“角色”。那么莫斯科在当时是什么样的呢？它已经有几个世纪的历史了，始建于12世纪末。当时发生的事情是，蒙古人席卷了现在的俄罗斯领土，在混乱之中，
the principality of Muscovy or Moscow had risen and swallowed up its neighbors, a bit like kind of Rome, I suppose, in the Italian peninsula, had become the sort of defining power of the area, of the region. And so by now it's a city of about 200,000 people, mainly out of wood. Very, it's always burning down. It always burns kind of basically every five years and every European visitors say, basically it's a pretty terrible place. It's full of fires. It's full burning down. Just kind of basically every five years. And European visitors say basically it's a pretty terrible place.
莫斯科公国崛起并吞并了它的邻居，我想这有点像意大利半岛上的罗马，成为了该地区具有决定性的力量。所以到了现在，它是一个拥有大约二十万人口的城市，房屋主要由木头建造。非常，它总是发生火灾。基本上每五年就会发生一次大火，而且所有欧洲游客都说，基本上这是一个相当糟糕的地方。到处都是火灾。到处都在着火。基本上每五年就这样一次。欧洲游客也说这基本上是个相当糟糕的地方。
It's full of fires, it's full of plague, it's very dangerous, the streets are full of kind of foot pads and beggars and whatnot. But there's a kind of exoticism to it, even then. So the culture of Moscow, of Muscovy, is this really interesting fusion of the legacy of Kievan Rus, the kind of the semi-state that Harold Hardrada visited a few weeks ago that had been established by the Vikings when they gone east. And it's that and it's the Mongols golden horde that has swept over it. But above all, orthodoxy.
到处都是火灾，到处都是瘟疫，非常危险，街道上到处都是流民、乞丐之类的人。但即使在那个时候，它也有着某种异国情调。所以莫斯科、莫斯科公国的文化是基辅罗斯遗产的奇妙融合，基辅罗斯就是哈罗德·哈德拉达几周前访问过的那个由维京人在向东时建立的半国家。不仅有这个，还有席卷而过的蒙古金帐汗国。但最重要的是，东正教。
So it sees itself as carrying the sort of precious gift of Christian orthodoxy, especially after the fall of Constantinople in 1453. So, it's come to call itself the Third Rome. So, we have basically inherited the flame from Constantinople that they had inherited from Rome, and we are keeping it alive. And Muscovy has expanded and expanded by 1547. Uh, the grand Prince Ivan the fourth, who we know as Ivan the terrible had crowned himself Caesar, not just of Muscovy, but of what he called all the rushes.
所以它视自己为基督教东正教珍贵礼物的传承者，特别是自从1453年君士坦丁堡陷落之后。因此，它开始称自己为“第三罗马”。所以，我们基本上继承了君士坦丁堡的火种，而他们又是从罗马那里继承的，我们正在让它延续下去。莫斯科公国不断扩张，到了1547年。呃，大公伊凡四世，也就是我们所知的伊凡雷帝，为自己加冕为凯撒，不仅是莫斯科公国的凯撒，还是他所称的“全罗斯”的凯撒。
So now you have people talking about Russia. In other words, and Caesar is Russified to Tsar to Tsar. Exactly. So he did that in the late 16th century. Um, but by the late 17th century said by 1672 when Peter the Great is born Russia is now the largest country on earth. It has expanded at a colossal rate So at this point they've already gone all the way across the forests of Siberia Largely uninhabited all the way to the Pacific
所以现在人们开始谈论俄罗斯了。换句话说，凯撒（Caesar）被俄语化成了沙皇（Tsar）。正是如此。所以他在16世纪末这样做了。但是到了17世纪末，也就是说到1672年彼得大帝出生时，俄罗斯已经是地球上面积最大的国家。它以惊人的速度扩张。所以此时他们已经穿过了西伯利亚的森林，那里大部分无人居住，一直延伸到太平洋。
They've gone down to the Caspian Sea and they're obviously very, you know, their borders go as far as basically Eastern Europe. So it's a huge country, by far the biggest on earth, but it is a kind of lumbering, weak giant. I think that's how most people perceive it because it's surrounded by enemies, all of which you would think are more, you know more deadly more powerful more impressive so there are three countries in particular play massive parts in the story so to the west of russia you have a country that is very dear to the hearts of members of the rest of the club and it's the polish lithuania and commonwealth very exciting to be cheering in the streets of our discord as you mentioned that yeah so Yeah. So the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth, which is this very strange state, all we need to say about it at this point is the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth
他们一直延伸到里海，而且显而易见，他们的边界基本上延伸到了东欧。所以这是一个巨大的国家，是地球上绝对最大的国家，但它是一个笨拙而虚弱的巨人。我想这是大多数人对它的看法，因为它被敌人包围，你可能会认为这些敌人更加致命、更加强大、更加令人印象深刻。因此，有三个国家在故事中扮演了极其重要的角色：在俄罗斯西部，有一个深受“俱乐部”成员喜爱的国家，那就是波兰立陶宛联邦。一提到这个，我们的Discord里就欢声雷动，非常激动，正如你所提到的，是的。所以。波兰立陶宛联邦是一个非常奇怪的国家，我们此时需要说的全部就是，波兰立陶宛联邦
has basically been kicking the Russians around for quite a long time. They'd actually occupied the Kremlin in Moscow in 1610. However, the Poles have passed their peak and are now in kind of a long-term decline, as we will see. Now, to the south, there is the Ottoman Empire. They are a massive superpower. So they control the Black Sea, they control the Balkans,
基本上已经把俄罗斯人按在地上摩擦了相当长一段时间。他们实际上在1610年占领了莫斯科的克里姆林宫。然而，波兰人已经过了他们的巅峰期，正如我们所将看到的，现在正处于长期衰退中。现在，在南部，有奥斯曼帝国。它们是一个庞大的超级大国。所以他们控制着黑海、巴尔干地区，
they through their vassals, the Tatars, they control Crimea and their influence goes well into Ukraine. Yeah, and they've, you know, they've been attacking Vienna. They have. So the Ottomans are a serious serious player and basically the Russians are, I've never challenged the Ottomans. They are kind of frightened of them. And then to the North, there is the great rival, which is Sweden. So the Swedish empire has only recently become a great power, but at this point in time, 1672, it controls Finland, Est, and Latvia, as well as parts of northern Germany.
通过他们的附庸鞑靼人，他们控制着克里米亚，并且他们的影响力深入乌克兰。是的，而且他们，你知道的，他们一直在进攻维也纳。确实如此。所以奥斯曼帝国是一个极其重要、极其强大的玩家，基本上俄罗斯人，我从来不敢挑战奥斯曼帝国。他们有点害怕奥斯曼人。然后向北，有伟大的对手，那就是瑞典。所以瑞典帝国不久前才成为一个强国，但在此时，即1672年，它控制着芬兰、爱沙尼亚、拉脱维亚以及德国北部的一部分。
And the Swedes are regarded as by far the most potent and formidable fighting force in Western Europe. So that's the legacy of Gustavus Adolphus, isn't it, who was the great sword of Protestantism in the Thirty Years' War. So Sweden is a Protestant power. The Ottoman Empire obviously is Muslim. Polish, Lithuanian, and it's all kinds of religions flourishing there, but essentially Catholic.
而且瑞典人被视为西欧最具潜力和最令人畏惧的战斗力量。所以这是古斯塔夫·阿道夫的遗产，不是吗？他在三十年战争中是新教的伟大之剑。所以瑞典是一个新教强国。奥斯曼帝国显然是穆斯林的。波兰立陶宛联邦那里各种宗教繁荣发展，但本质上是天主教的。
So Russia as the Orthodox power is surrounded not just by geopolitical rivals, but by religious rivals and presumably that intense because it's the only Orthodox power because Constantinople has been conquered, that must presumably intensify both its sense of being beleaguered by heretics, but also the sense of mission that it has as God's chosen vessel. Absolutely, it does. Absolutely. So orthodoxy is probably the defining, the single defining thing about Russian culture. So to give you a sense of what Russian society is like, it has four times as many people as, let's say, Sweden. But about the same number as Poland, right?
所以俄罗斯作为东正教大国，不仅被地缘政治对手包围，还被宗教对手包围。据推测，由于它是唯一的东正教强国——因为君士坦丁堡已经被征服——这必定会加剧它一方面作为异教徒包围下的受困感，另一方面作为上帝选民的使命感。当然，确实如此。绝对如此。所以东正教可能是俄罗斯文化中最具决定性的单一特征。为了让你对俄罗斯社会的状况有个概念，它的人口大约是瑞典的四倍。但大约和波兰差不多，对吧？
Right, exactly. And not nearly as many, say, as France. No, nowhere near as many as France. And very, very few of these people live in towns. There are very few Russian towns. The vast majority are illiterate peasants and sort of culturally, it feels very different from let's say Sweden or Poland, because frankly, to use a word that academics don't like to use now, it is very backward. So because the Orthodox Church has such a stranglehold, it has no universities, it has no schools, it has no playwrights, it has no scientists, it has no parliament, it has
对，没错。而且远没有法国那么多，对吧？不，远没有法国那么多。而且极少有人住在城镇里。俄罗斯城镇极少。绝大多数人都是目不识丁的农民，从文化上讲，它感觉与瑞典或波兰非常不同，因为坦率地说，用一个学者现在不喜欢用的词来形容，它非常落后。因为东正教拥有如此绝对的控制权，它没有大学，没有学校，没有剧作家，没有科学家，没有议会，没有
no newspapers, it has no playwrights, it has no scientists, it has no parliament, it has no newspapers, it has no navy. Right. And the Navy, I mean, that's in large part because it has no ports, right? I mean, it has Archangel on the north, so the Arctic, but often that's frozen, that's frozen for six months, whatever. It doesn't have a port on on the Black Sea. No, and it doesn't have a port on the Baltic. No, because the Baltic, the Black Sea is an Ottoman Lake. And't have a port on the Baltic. No. Because the Black Sea is an Ottoman lake and the Baltic is essentially a Swedish lake at this point. That's right.
报纸，没有剧作家，没有科学家，没有议会，没有报纸，没有海军。没错。至于海军，我的意思是，很大程度上是因为它没有港口，对吧？我的意思是，它北部有阿尔汉格尔斯克，也就是北冰洋，但那里经常结冰，结冰六个月什么的。它在黑海没有港口。没有，而且它在波罗的海也没有港口。没有，因为波罗的海，黑海是奥斯曼帝国的内湖。也没有波罗的海的港口。没有。因为黑海是奥斯曼帝国的内湖，而波罗的海在此时本质上是瑞典的内湖。没错。
So a way to think of Russia is as quite effectively landlocked and isolated country. When people go to Russia, they say, you're European ambassadors and whatnot. They say it is like going a little bit backwards in time. Even though the way in which people talk about the Tsar is feels sort of he's a magnificent figure. He is the father of the Russian family. His noblemen prostrate themselves in front of the Tsar. They use this sort of language, I'm your humble slave, I'm but a lowly worm, all of this sort of thing.
所以看待俄罗斯的一个方式是，它实际上是一个内陆且孤立的国家。当人们去俄罗斯时，他们说，比如欧洲大使之类的人。他们说这就有点像时光倒流。尽管人们谈论沙皇的方式让人觉得他是一个宏伟的人物。他是俄罗斯家庭之父。他的贵族在沙皇面前顶礼膜拜。他们使用这种语言：我是你卑微的奴隶，我不过是一条卑微的虫子，诸如此类的话。
If you talk to the Tsar, you have to use his full official title at all times, and you can never repeat what the Tsar has said to you. There is this sort of pervasive culture of conservatism and deference, I guess. And nowhere is that more pronounced, of course, than the Kremlin itself. So again, as with Moscow, I think we should give a sort of portrait to the Kremlin so people who are not familiar with it can get a sense of what it's like. It's basically a citadel. The word means a citadel.
如果你和沙皇谈话，你必须在任何时候都使用他的全称头衔，而且你绝不能重复沙皇对你说过的话。这里存在着一种无处不在的保守和顺从文化，我想。而且没有任何地方比克里姆林宫本身更能体现这一点。所以，与莫斯科一样，我认为我们应该对克里姆林宫进行一番描绘，好让不熟悉它的人对它有一个概念。它基本上是一座城堡。这个词的意思就是城堡。
It's a citadel within the city. It is cut off from the rest of the city by a moat and by huge walls. And at the centre of the Kremlin, where a lot of the dramas of Peter's life will play out, there is Cathedral Square and there are three cathedrals. If you've ever been, I have been, and it's an amazing, amazing place to visit. There's these medieval cathedrals and there's a palace called the Palace of Facets, which still stands with a grand staircase running down the outside, which is called the Red Staircase and there's going to be some very exciting action to come.
它是城市中的一座城堡。它被一条护城河和巨大的城墙与城市的其他部分隔开。在克里姆林宫的中心，彼得生前的许多戏剧性事件都将在这里上演，那里有大教堂广场，有三座大教堂。如果你去过的话——我去过——那是一个非常、非常棒的参观地点。那里有中世纪的大教堂，还有一座名为“多棱宫”的宫殿，它至今仍然耸立着，外部有一条通往地面的宏伟楼梯，被称为“红楼梯”，接下来将会有一些非常精彩的行动发生。
The Red Staircase will be reddened. It will indeed. So, let's talk about Peter's family. His father is called Alexis. His nickname is Tishaisi, which means the quietest. He's monkish and kind of pious and modest and whatnot. And Natalia, his wife, is his second wife. So it's this classic thing where the czar has had two wives and there's a little bit of tension between the two sides of the family. So the first
红楼梯将被染红。确实如此。那么，让我们来谈谈彼得的家庭。他的父亲名叫阿列克谢。他的绰号是米沙伊西（Tishaisi），意为“最安静的人”。他像个僧侣，既虔诚又谦逊，诸如此类。而他的妻子娜塔莉亚是他的第二任妻子。所以这是一个典型的例子，沙皇娶了两位妻子，家族的两派之间存在着一丝紧张关系。所以第一
marriage was to a woman called Maria Milislavskaya and she had two surviving sons, lots of daughters and two surviving sons, and one is called Fedor and he's 11 years old and he is bright and a nice chap but he's very years old and he is bright, a bright and a nice chap, but he's very sickly. And the other one is called Ivan, who is five and who is, he's kind of half blind. He's got a very serious speech impediment. He's like Claudius only. Yeah, exactly. More so anyway, their mother, Maria Milislovskaya had died and Alexis had to
婚姻对象是一个名叫玛丽亚·米利斯拉夫斯卡娅的女子，她育有几个幸存的女儿、两个幸存的儿子，其中一个叫费奥多尔，十一岁，聪明可爱，但身体非常虚弱。另一个叫伊万，五岁，有点半盲，有很严重的语言障碍。他就像克劳迪斯一样。是的，完全如此。总之更是如此，他们的母亲玛丽亚·米利斯拉夫斯卡娅已经去世，阿列克谢不得不
choose another bride and the rules are she has to be Orthodox. So it's basically has to be Russian. And they had this, they would always have a kind of bridal show of candidates. So these women would be from the noble families, the boyar families would be brought to the courts and they'd have to prove their virginity. And some of them might even be serfs, isn't that right? That's right. Yeah. It's the whole spread. But I might also write that actually this is all a bit of a sham. Yes. Because the sarr has already decided who he wants. He has been a real kind of coup de foudre. It hasn't. Well, so basically it's very Henry VIII. His chief minister, who's a guy called Artamon Matveyev, has pushed forward his ward, who is called Natalia Narishkina. Now she's supposedly very
选择另一位新娘，规矩是她必须信奉东正教，所以基本上必须是俄罗斯人。他们通常会举办一场候选新娘秀，这些女子来自贵族家庭、波雅尔家庭，被带到宫廷接受贞洁检验。其中一些甚至可能是农奴，对吧？没错。是的，各种阶层都有。但我也得说，其实这一切都有点像是一场骗局。是的。因为沙皇已经决定了自己想要谁，他经历了一见钟情。其实并没有。嗯，所以这非常像亨利八世。他的首席大臣阿塔蒙·马特维耶夫极力推荐他的受监护人娜塔莉亚·纳雷什基娜。现在她据说非常
beautiful, very dark, very sort of demure. And Alexis took a massive shine to her. She's Peter the Great's mother. So they get married. And obviously, you know, this is brilliant news for the chief minister who's Matt Vaev, who is a really interesting character. And it's that's his surname, isn't it? He's not called Matt Vaev. No, he's not called Matt Vaev. His name is Artamon Matt Vaev, exactly. He's interesting because he really anticipates Peter, because he is a meritocrat and a moderniser. He's the son of a diplomat. He collects books. He has his own laboratory and his own private theatre. He's really interested in kind of Western innovations. And what is more,
美丽、文静、非常端庄。阿列克谢对她一见倾心。她就是彼得大帝的母亲。于是他们结婚了。显而易见，这对于首席大臣马特维耶夫来说是个天大的好消息，他是一个非常有趣的人物。那是他的姓氏，对吧？他不叫马特维耶夫。不，他不叫马特维耶夫。他的名字叫阿塔蒙·马特维耶夫，没错。他很有趣，因为他真正预示了彼得时代的到来，他是个唯才论者和现代化主义者。他是外交官的儿子，收集书籍，拥有自己的实验室和私人剧院。他对西方的新事物非常感兴趣，而且
he is married to somebody from our own island. So his wife is called Mary Hamilton, and she is the daughter of a Scottish royalist who fled abroad after the execution of Charles I. Because although the Russians are quite xenophobic, the Tsar himself has a lot of sympathy for exiles from the civil wars in Britain, doesn't he? Because he's absolutely appalled that an anointed king has had his head chopped off. Exactly. And actually, so that story about the Chief Minister, Matveyev, being married to this woman, tells a wider story. So during the 17th century, merchants and diplomats
他娶了我们自己岛上的人。他的妻子名叫玛丽·汉密尔顿，是一名苏格兰保王党的女儿，查理一世被处决后逃到了国外。尽管俄罗斯人相当排外，但沙皇本人对英国内战中的流亡者抱有很大同情，不是吗？因为他对受膏的国王被砍头感到极其震惊。没错。事实上，关于首席大臣马特维耶夫娶了这位女子的故事，反映了更广泛的背景。在17世纪，商人和外交官
had been arriving in Russia in ever greater numbers and Alexis had established a segregated quarter outside Moscow, which comes to be known as the German suburb. Because they think all foreigners basically are Germans, is that right? Yes, exactly. And they say all these Germans, whether they be Dutch, Scottish, English or whatever, or indeed German, they have to go and live there. There's about 3000 people there and they they're allowed to keep up It's a bit I guess it's a bit like living in one of those compounds in the Middle East
源源不断地涌入俄罗斯，阿列克谢在莫斯科郊外建立了一个隔离区，后来被称为德国人区。因为他们基本上认为所有外国人都叫德国人，是这样吗？是的，完全如此。他们说所有这些德国人，无论是荷兰人、苏格兰人、英国人还是其他什么人，或者真的是德国人，都必须去那里居住。那里大约有3,000人，他们被允许保持——这有点像住在中东的那些大院里一样吧
Yeah, you know in Saudi or something exactly there they can put on plays they can smoke tobacco Which is disapproved of in Russia they can mix with women again Which is the mixing of the of the sexist is disapproved of in Russia And we know that their influence is spreading outside, that people are copying them. Because when Peter was three years old, Alexis had to give a rollicking to his courtiers and said to them, you know, stop adopting German customs, stop cutting your hair and wearing hats of foreign design. So the Russians take all this stuff, which seems so comical, they take it incredibly seriously. If you turned up smoking and wearing a foreign hat, you would be in enormous trouble with the Tsar.
是的，你知道的，比如在沙特阿拉伯或其他地方，完全没错。他们可以在那里上演戏剧，可以抽烟——这在俄罗斯是不被赞许的，他们可以男女混杂——同样，男女混杂在俄罗斯也是不被赞许的。我们知道他们的影响正在向外扩散，人们正在效仿他们。因为当彼得三岁时，阿列克谢不得不训斥他的朝臣们，对他们说，你知道的，不要再采用德国的风俗，不要再剪头发和戴外国款式的帽子了。所以俄罗斯人对所有这些看似滑稽的东西采取了极其认真的态度。如果你抽着烟、戴着外国帽子出现，你会给沙皇惹上巨大的麻烦。
But also with the Orthodox Church, because for complicated reasons that I'm not entirely sure of, they've essentially see that smoking and foreign hats as anathema to God. Yeah, that's right. Literally. Yes. Or into being clean sha God. Yeah, that's right. Literally. Yes. Or until you've been clean shaven. So you know, worse. Yeah. With that would be regarded as very poor behavior.
而且还会惹恼东正教会，因为由于种种我不太确定的复杂原因，他们基本上将吸烟和外国帽子视为对上帝的大不敬。是的，没错。千真万确。是的。或者直到你刮干净胡子。所以你知道的，更糟。是的。那会被视为非常恶劣的行为。
Now there's, there are hints that Peter's mother, Natalia also likes this fascination with Western habits that she's probably got this from Matveyev because she's been spending so much time in his house. So she clearly doesn't really like the atmosphere of the Kremlin, which is all bells, incense, beards, you know, sort of dark corridors. So when Peter's a little boy, he and his mother spend most of their time outside the city. And we only have a couple of kind of glimpses of him.
现在有迹象表明，彼得的母亲娜塔莉亚也很喜欢这种对西方习俗的迷恋，她可能是从马特维耶夫那里学来的，因为她在他的宅邸度过了大量时间。所以她显然很不喜欢克里姆林宫的氛围，那里全都是钟声、香火、胡须，还有阴暗的走廊。因此，当彼得还是个小男孩时，他和母亲把大部分时间都花在城外。我们只能偶尔瞥见他几眼。
There's a story about him riding with some dwarfs on a coach. I mean, there are a lot of dwarfs in this story. But then the first of many bombshells in this story, his father catches a chill and dies at the age of 47 in 1676. So that's what was Peter. He's about three and a half, something like that. And he is succeeded by the older of Peter's two half-brothers, so this bloke Fedor, who's now 14, and he is so sickly that he had to be carried to his own coronation. So that's actually really bad news, you would think, for Natalia and for Peter, because the old family, the previous wife's family are now in the driving seat, the Milošlavskys,
有一个关于他坐着马车和一些侏儒一起兜风的故事。我的意思是，这个故事里有很多侏儒。但随后，故事中的许多重磅炸弹之一发生了，1676年，他的父亲着凉并在47岁时去世。那时的彼得大约多大？他大约三岁半，诸如此类。接替他的是彼得两个同父异母哥哥中较大的一个，也就是这个叫费奥多尔的家伙，现在14岁，他身体虚弱到必须被人抬着去参加自己的加冕礼。所以你可能会认为，这对娜塔莉亚和彼得来说绝对是个坏消息，因为老家族、前妻的家族现在掌权了，也就是米洛斯拉夫斯基家族，
and running through this story is a sort of rivalry between these two clans, the Mila Slavskys, who were the first wife's family and the Talia's family, who were the Nurezhkins. And, and Matt. So Matt Vaev, he, chief minister, he is stripped of all his property. He's arrested and he's sent to an obscure town in the Arctic circle. Oh God. So that's bad news for him.
贯穿这个故事的是两个宗族之间的某种竞争，一个是米洛斯拉夫斯基家族（第一任妻子的家族），另一个是娜塔莉亚的家族（纳雷什金家族）。还有马特。所以首席大臣马特维耶夫被剥夺了所有的财产。他被逮捕，并被流放到北极圈内的一个偏远小镇。天哪。所以这对他是坏消息。
So now Peter sort of disappears from sight inside the Kremlin. It's not that bad. Fedor is actually his godfather and is actually quite nice to him and make sure he's educated and all this sort of thing. No, no, no, no, no, no, not at all. I think the sort of, so some of these people you think, oh, they must be the most awful butchers and kind of callous, cruel. This is not the case at all. So Fedor is quite nice to Peter. And he's a little bit of a reformer Fedor.
所以现在彼得在克里姆林宫里隐形了。情况其实没那么糟。费奥多尔实际上是他的教父，对他相当不错，确保他受过教育等等。不，不，不，不，不，完全不是这样。我觉得，这些人中的一些人，你以为他们一定是极其可怕的屠夫，冷酷而残酷。事实并非如此。所以费奥多尔对彼得挺好的。费奥多尔稍微有点改革倾向。
But he dies young as well. So he rules for six years and then he dies. And now we have a big succession crisis. So 1682, Peter is 10 years old. He's this big, big boy, huge and bright, but he's only a child, of course. And he has one remaining half brother who is Ivan, who is 16 years old. He can't walk. He can't see.
但他也很早就去世了。他统治了六年就去世了。现在我们面临着巨大的皇位继承危机。1682年，彼得十岁。他是一个长得很高大的男孩，巨大而聪慧，但毕竟只是个孩子。他还有一个在世的同父异母哥哥伊万，十六岁。他不会走路，也看不见。
He speaks only with difficulty. So he's also not a, he's not an outstanding candidate. And there are two camps. Basically. There's the Miloslavskis who want Ivan and there's the Naryshkins He's not an outstanding candidate. And there are two camps basically. There's the Miloslavskis who want Ivan and there's the Naryshkins who want Peter. And there's great arguments. There's actually arguments around Fedul's deathbed. And the Patriot goes out onto the red staircase and he says to the crowd, who do you want
他说话都很困难。所以他也不是一个出色的候选人。基本上有两个阵营。米洛斯拉夫斯基家族想要伊万，而纳雷什金家族他不是一个出色的候选人。基本上有两个阵营。米洛斯拉夫斯基家族想要伊万，而纳雷什金家族想要彼得。争论非常激烈。事实上，在费奥多尔临终的床榻周围就充满了争论。大主教走到红色楼梯上，对人群说，你们想要
to rule? Do you want Ivan Alexievich or do you want Peter Alexievich son of Alexis and the crowd shout for Peter oh we want Peter the patriot says brilliant he goes back inside he kneels before the 10 year old Peter and says will you be Azar with your mother Natalia as the regent yes brilliant get that bloke back from the Arctic Circle Matt yeah Matt Vaev get him back he can be chief minister again so it all looks great for Peter okay he's 10 but you know everything has gone Six circle Matt. Yeah, Matt, they have get him back. He can be chief minister again. So it all looks great for Peter. OK, he's 10, but, you know, everything has gone his way.
谁来统治？你们想要阿列克谢维奇之子伊万·阿列克谢维奇，还是想要阿列克谢之子彼得·阿列克谢维奇？人群高呼彼得的名字，哦，我们要彼得！大主教说，太棒了！他走回室内，跪在十岁的彼得面前说，你愿意成为沙皇，由你的母亲娜塔莉亚担任摄政王吗？太棒了！把那个被流放到北极圈的家伙接回来，马特，对，马特维耶夫，把他接回来，他可以重新担任首席大臣！所以这一切对彼得来说看起来棒极了。好吧，他才十岁，但你知道的，一切都朝着他的方向发展圆形马特。是的，马特，他们把他弄回来。他可以再次成为首席大臣。所以对彼得来说一切看起来都很棒。好吧，他十岁，但你知道的，一切都如他所愿。
What could possibly go wrong, Dominic? There is a twist. There is an extraordinary twist. So I mentioned offhand that Peter's father's first wife, Maria Milislovskaya, had had a lot of daughters. Now, normally these daughters were just shoved into a place in the palace called the Terem, like the kind of harem, and never let out again, princesses.
多米尼克，怎么可能会出问题呢？有个转折。一个极其戏剧性的转折。所以我顺便提过，彼得父亲的第一任妻子玛丽亚·米利斯拉夫斯卡娅生了很多女儿。通常这些女儿只是被塞进宫殿里一个叫做捷列姆（Terem）的地方，就像后宫一样，再也不让她们出来，作为公主。
But there's one of them who is clearly a really exceptional woman. She's called Sophia. She's almost 25. She's very clever. She's very brave. She had been educated alongside her brother Fedor, which is very unusual. And when Fedor was our she had gone to his council meetings. She talked to his ministers. I mean, this is really exceptional, isn't it? Because it is hard to overemphasize how chauvinist Russian political culture is. Extraordinary details about how when a woman is married, the father will hand over a whip to the man who's marrying.
但其中有一个显然是个非常杰出的女性。她叫索菲亚。她快二十五岁了。她非常聪明，非常勇敢。她曾和弟弟费奥多尔一起接受教育，这非常罕见。当费奥多尔掌权时，她曾去参加他的内阁会议。她和他的大臣们交谈。我的意思是，这真的很不寻常，不是吗？因为很难过分夸大俄罗斯政治文化的大男子主义色彩。一些非同寻常的细节表明，当女人结婚时，父亲会把一根鞭子交到结婚的男子手中。
Now you're in charge. It's your turn. Yeah, I know. It's terrible. So from Sevilla's point of view, the accession of Peter, her half-brother, that's terrible news. Like she's going to be shoved into this sort of corner of the palace and never come out again and she's a spirited. Yeah.
现在由你做主了。轮到你了。是的，我知道。太糟糕了。所以从索菲亚的角度来看，她同父异母的弟弟彼得即位，这绝对是个坏消息。就像她会被塞进宫殿的某个角落里，再也无法出来，而且她是一个很有骨气的人。是的。
Who's attending the council. And so it kind of death. And so she basically says to the patriarch, what's at least have joint monarchs, Peter and my brother, Yvonne, because if you, if you don't, you know, that's the end of me kind of thing. So she makes a massive spectacle of herself. She goes to federal's funeral. She breaks down in tears, very conspicuously.
她出席了议会。这犹如末日降临。所以她基本上对大主教说，至少让我们实行联合君主制吧，彼得和我弟弟伊万，因为如果你不这样做，你知道的，我这辈子就完了。因此，她大张旗鼓地表现自己。她去参加费奥多尔的葬礼。她情绪崩溃，泪流满面，非常引人注目。
She says, um, federal was actually poisoned. My sisters and I are in danger for our lives. All of this kind of thing. So she's sort of reminding everybody that she is, um, that she's still there. But what's crucial is that she has very powerful allies. And these allies are effectively the Praetorian Guard of Moscow, who are the Streltsy. And the Streltsy are Russia's first ever professional kind
她说，嗯，费奥多尔实际上是被毒死的。我和我的姐姐们正处于生命危险之中。诸如此类的话。所以她有点在提醒每个人，她，嗯，她还在那里。但至关重要的是，她拥有非常强大的盟友。这些盟友实际上是莫斯科的近卫军，也就是斯特列利齐（Streltsy）。斯特列利齐是俄罗斯有史以来第一支职业近卫
of standing army. They were founded by Ivan the Terrible a century earlier. There's 22 regiments of them. They're musketeers and pikemen. And they're stationed in Moscow. They're stationed in Moscow. They wear the most amazing outfits. They have these kind of long... They wear kaftans, don't they? Kaftans, yeah. And yellow boots and kind of fur hats and stuff. They look brilliant.
常备军。它们是一个世纪前由伊万雷帝创立的。他们有22个团。他们是火枪手和长矛手。他们驻扎在莫斯科。他们驻扎在莫斯科。他们穿着最奇妙的制服。他们有这种长长的……他们穿卡夫坦长袍，对吧？卡夫坦长袍，对。还有黄色靴子和各种皮帽之类的。他们看起来棒极了。
You see, fur hats? I would be menaced by a man in a fur hat. Would you? And yellow boots. Yellow boots, I mean, but a kaftan. Yeah. It's a bit. Yellow boots, I mean, but a caftan. Yeah, I know. It's a bit Narnia, I think. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, they're in there. That's exactly what it is. It's actually San Francisco in 1967. Yeah. They basically become a hereditary cast. So you pass down your place in the Streltsy from father to son, but the Streltsy are always falling out among themselves. The officers treat their men like absolute dirt.
你看，皮帽？我会觉得戴皮帽的男人很有威胁感。是吗？还有黄色靴子。黄色靴子，我的意思是，还有卡夫坦长袍。是的。有点……黄色靴子，我的意思是，还有卡夫坦长袍。是的，我知道。我觉得这有点像纳尼亚传奇。是的。是的。无论如何，他们就在那里。这正是它的写照。它实际上就是1967年的旧金山。是的。他们基本上成了一个世袭阶层。所以你在斯特列利齐的职位由父传子，但斯特列利齐内部总是争吵不断。军官们对待手下的士兵如同粪土一般。
And what is more, the officers get the men to basically do things like dig their gardens for them and kind of do odd jobs and the men hate doing that. So while, by coincidence, while Fedor has been dying, there's been a mutiny among some of the Streltsy. They've put pikemen and musketeers, they accuse their officers of abusing them, stealing their money. And Sophia and her allies use this, they're like, brilliant, we can use this, we can use these mutineers.
不仅如此，军官们还让士兵们帮他们做诸如挖花园之类的杂务，士兵们极其痛恨这种事。因此，在巧合之下，当费奥多尔垂死之际，部分斯特列利齐士兵发生了哗变。他们是长矛手和火枪手，他们指责军官虐待他们、窃取他们的钱财。索菲亚和她的盟友们利用了这一点，他们想，太棒了，我们可以利用这一点，我们可以利用这些哗变者。
And they go to the Streltsy, they clearly spread rumors among them. They say, listen, Fedor was poisoned by foreign doctors working for the Nerishkins. If Peter becomes Tsar, then foreigners will be given all the commands in the army and orthodoxy will be undermined. And actually, Natalia, Peter's mother, is planning a massive crackdown against you, against the Streltsy. So you should do something about this. So this clearly begins to seep into the sort of the Streltsy's imagination. And then the denouement comes on the morning of the 15th of May. So two of Sophia's mates, her sort of aristocratic mates, ride into the Streltsy quarter of Moscow and they say the Norishkins are taking over the Kremlin,
他们去找斯特列利齐，显然在他们中间散布谣言。他们说，听着，费奥多尔是被为纳雷什金家族工作的外国医生毒害的。如果彼得当上沙皇，那么外国将获得军队的所有指挥权，正统信仰将受到破坏。事实上，彼得的母亲娜塔莉亚正计划对你们、对斯特列利齐进行大规模的镇压。所以你们应该采取点行动。这显然开始渗入斯特列利齐的想象中。接着，结局在5月15日的早晨降临了。索菲亚的两个朋友，她的贵族死党，骑马冲进莫斯科的斯特列利齐军营区，说纳雷什金家族正在接管克里姆林宫，
they have murdered Ivan, which is actually not true, and they're going to kill the whole royal family quickly to the Kremlin, to arms! And the Streltsy rush out of bed, they put on their armour, they get their weapons and they march into the centre of Moscow, their banners flying and drums beating and they're shouting, we're going to the Kremlin, we're going to the Kremlin, we're going to kill the traitors. They get to the Kremlin. The guards at the Kremlin let them in and they swarm into Cathedral Square, which is in front of this palace with the red staircase. And they're shouting, this is basically a mob of men waving pikes and shouting, give us the Nourishkins, give us Matveyev, death to the traitors, death to the foreigners, all this sort of thing. Inside,
他们谋杀了伊万——这其实并非事实，他们要杀死整个皇室，快去克里姆林宫，武装起来！斯特列利齐士兵从床上冲出来，穿上盔甲，拿起武器，打着旗帜、敲着战鼓开进莫斯科市中心，高喊着，我们要去克里姆林宫，我们要去克里姆林宫，我们要去杀死叛徒。他们到达了克里姆林宫。克里姆林宫的卫兵放他们进去了，他们蜂拥进入大教堂广场，也就是带有红色楼梯的那座宫殿前方。他们高喊着，这基本上是一帮挥舞着长矛、大喊大叫的暴徒，把纳雷什金交出来，把马特维耶夫交出来，叛徒去死，外国人去死，诸如此类。里面，
you know, Natalia, Peter's mother, Peter, this guy, Matt Vaev, they're all there, oh gosh, what are we going to do? And Matt Vaev says to Natalia, look, you have to calm them down, you have to tell them this is all nonsense. Go out onto the red staircase, take the two boys, Ivan and Peter, show them to the stroller seat. So Dominic, this is quite like Marie Antoinette confronted by the women from Paris. It's exactly what it is. It's exactly what I was thinking that myself. Natalia shows tremendous courage. She takes the two boys, 16 year old Ivani can barely walk.
你知道的，娜塔莉亚（彼得的母亲）、彼得、这个叫马特维耶夫的家伙，他们都在那里，哦天哪，我们该怎么办？马特维耶夫对娜塔莉亚说，听着，你必须让群情激奋的他们平静下来，你必须告诉他们这全都是无稽之谈。走到红色楼梯上去，带上两个男孩，伊万和彼得，让他们在斯特列利齐面前露面。所以多米尼克，这很像玛丽·安托瓦内特面对来自巴黎的妇女们。这正是它的写照。我自己刚才也是这么想的。娜塔莉亚表现出巨大的勇气。她带上两个男孩，16岁的伊万几乎都走不动路了。
He's meant to be dead. He's meant to be dead, but he's not dead. She takes them out onto the staircase. There's priests and kind of the boyars, noblemen behind her. And below there's this massive mob of men in yellow boots, yeah, waving their pikes and shouting for her blood. And she says, here are the Tsar and the Tsarovich. There are no traitors.
他本来应该死了。他本来应该死了，但他没死。她把他们带到楼梯上。身后是牧师和波雅尔贵族们。下面是一大群穿着黄色靴子的暴徒，是的，挥舞着长矛，高喊着要她的血。她说，沙皇和皇太子都在这里。没有叛徒。
You have been deceived. And some of the Streltsy don't believe her and they go up the stairs. They go right up to Ivan. They say, are you really Ivan Alexeyevich? And he says, yes, I am. I am kind of thing. And they're like, hmm. And then, hmm. And then eventually they go back down the stairs.
你们被骗了。有些斯特列利齐士兵不相信她，他们上了楼梯。他们径直走到伊万面前。他们说，你真的是伊万·阿列克谢维奇吗？他说，是的，我是。类似这样的话。他们想，嗯。然后，嗯。最后他们又走下了楼梯。
Matveyev steps forward. He's the chief minister and he says, look chaps, you've been misled. This is all a massive misunderstanding. Um, I will give you all a pardon. You should go home. And do you know what? It works. They, they seem to listen.
马特维耶夫走上前去。他是首席大臣，他说，听着伙计们，你们被误导了。这完全是个巨大的误会。嗯，我特赦你们所有人。你们回家吧。你知道吗？管用了。他们，他们似乎听进去了。
He says, brilliant. He goes back inside. But Dominic, do you know what a Roman works. They, they seem to listen. He says, brilliant. He goes back inside. But Dominic, do you know what a Roman emperor would have done in that situation? He would have given them a massive bung. Yeah, he would. He'd have given them a large amount of money. So that's where I think Matt went wrong.
他说：太棒了。他走回里面。但多米尼克，你知道一个罗马的皇帝在这种情况下会怎么做吗？他会给他们一大笔封口费。没错，他会给的。他会给他们一大笔钱。所以我觉得马特在那里就做错了。
Well, and also what goes wrong now is one of their commanders steps out onto the red staircase. So one of the nobles who's like normally in charge of them, who's a guy called Prince Michael Dolgoruky. And he says, well, you've been told now you've disgraced yourselves. You've let yourselves down. You're at Moscow down. You've let the good name of the Streltsy down. Go back home to your barracks.
嗯，而且现在出问题的地方是，他们的指挥官之一走到了红色阶梯上。也就是通常管着他们的那些贵族之一，一个叫米哈伊尔·多尔戈鲁基亲王的人。他说，好了，你们现在都被告知了，你们已经自取其辱了。你们让自己失望了。你们让莫斯科失望了。你们让斯特列利齐的好名声蒙羞了。回你们的军营去吧。
And if you don't do as you're told, I will flog you. And this is very, very this is a foolish move from Prince Dolgoruky, because when the Streltsy hear this, they say, what? Oh, actually, we're not going to... No, forget it. The moot is back on. They charge up the stairs, they grab him, and they throw this bloke over the balustrade onto the pikes of the men below.
如果你们不听指挥，我就鞭笞你们。这绝对、绝对是多尔戈鲁基亲王的一个愚蠢举动，因为当斯特列利齐听到这话时，他们说，什么？哦，其实，我们不打算……算了吧，暴动继续。他们冲上台阶，抓住他，把这家伙从栏杆上扔下去，正好砸在下面士兵的长矛上。
So he's impaled on the pikes. Well, that's him told. Yeah. Now, there's a wonderful book about Peter the Great by Robert K. Massey and I've had to restrain myself from just quoting enormous chunks, but it's one of my, he loves, he really goes for it in this passage. He says, the crowd roared its approval shouting, cut him to pieces. Within a few seconds, the quivering body was butchered, bespattering everyone around with
于是他被长矛串了起来。好吧，这下他可听进去了。嗯。现在，有一本关于彼得大帝的精彩著作，作者是罗伯特·K·马西，我不得不克制自己不去引用大段大段的内容，但这是我的……在这段里他真的很放得开。他说，人群发出赞许的咆哮，大喊着把他碎尸万段。几秒钟内，那具抽搐的躯体就被肢解了，
blood. That's my kind of praise. This is just the beginning. So the Streltsy now go absolutely, they go berserk. They charge up the stairs, they've drawn their weapons, they burst him. The first person they see is Matveyev, who was stunned to see them because he thought everything had passed off successfully. He sorted it out.
鲜血溅得到处都是。这正合我意。这仅仅是个开始。所以斯特列利齐现在彻底狂暴了。他们冲上台阶，拔出武器，闯了进去。他们看到的第一个人是马特维耶夫，他看到他们时惊呆了，因为他以为一切都顺利过去了。他已经把事情平息了。
He's chatting to Natalia who's still holding the hands of the two boys. They grab Matveyev, they drag him outside, he's kicking and screaming, they throw him over the balustrade too, onto the waiting halberd points, and he is hacked to pieces too. So the square is covered with the blooded pieces of Prince Dolgoruky and this bloke the Chief Minister. And now the Streltsy are like, well, in for a penny, in for a pound. So now they really kind of turn it up to 11. And what about Natalia and Peter and Ivan? Well, she's there quivering with the two boys while the Streltsy are charging into the palace around them.
他正在和娜塔莉亚聊天，娜塔莉亚手里还拉着两个男孩。他们抓住马特维耶夫，把他拖到外面，他又踢又叫，他们也把他扔过栏杆，扔到了蓄势待发的戟尖上，他也同样被砍成了碎片。于是广场上到处都是多尔戈鲁基亲王和这位首席大臣的血肉碎片。现在斯特列利齐觉得，来都来了，干脆一不做二不休。所以他们把音量直接开到了最大。那娜塔莉亚、彼得和伊万呢？嗯，当斯特列利齐冲进他们周围的宫殿时，她正和两个男孩在那里瑟瑟发抖。
They're basically in a corner kind of sobbing terrified. And the weird thing is that they're almost ignored. The Streltsy are just like, let's go through the palace and kill everybody. So they round up they do what you would always do in this situation. I think you round up the dwarves. They round up the court dwarves and they say to the dwarves, if you don't tell us where the Nurishkin family are, all the members of the Nurishkin clan, we will kill you.
他们基本上缩在角落里，吓得瑟瑟发抖。奇怪的是，他们几乎被忽视了。斯特列利齐只想穿过宫殿杀光所有人。于是他们把侏儒集中起来，在这种情况下你总会这么做。我想你会把侏儒们召集起来。他们把宫廷里的侏儒召集起来，对侏儒们说，如果你们不告诉我们努什金家族在哪里，努什金家族的所有成员都在哪，我们就杀了你们。
So the dwarves rather let that good name of dwarves down, I think, because they do betray a lot of the Nurishkins. I think you're being very harsh there on the dwarves. I mean, what would you do in that situation? I'd have thrown my lot in with the Streltsy hours before, I think it's fair to say. Yeah, I would. So the Streltsy are kind of rampaging through the palace.
所以我觉得侏儒们有点辜负了侏儒的好名声，因为他们确实背叛了许多努什金家族的人。我觉得你对侏儒太严厉了。我是说，在那种情况下你会怎么做？我想公平地说，我几个小时前就会向斯特列利齐投诚了。没错，我会的。所以斯特列利齐正在宫殿里横冲直撞。
They're thrusting pikes into the cupboards and stuff in case there's anyone hiding there. To quote Robert K. Massey again, those who were caught were dragged to the red staircase and thrown over the balustrade. Their bodies were dragged from the Kremlin through the Spassky gate into Red Square, where they were tossed onto a growing pyramid
他们把长矛刺进橱柜之类的东西里，以防有人藏在里面。再次引用罗伯特·K·马西的话：那些被抓到的人被拖到红色阶梯上扔过栏杆。他们的尸体从克里姆林宫穿过斯帕斯基门被拖到红场，扔到了一座不断增高的
of dismembered human parts. So this goes on all afternoon. They're just killing dozens of people. And at nightfall, at last, the Streltsy get tired. It's quite tiring work, I think, hacking people to pieces with a pike or something so they get tired and the violence begins to die down. But Tom, the whole crisis is far from over and we'll find out what happens next after the break.
人类残肢金字塔上。所以这持续了整个下午。他们只是在屠杀几十个人。直到夜幕降临，斯特列利齐终于累了。我想，用长矛把人砍成碎片是一件相当累人的工作，所以他们累了，暴力开始平息。但汤姆，整场危机远未结束，中场休息后我们将揭晓接下来发生的事情。
Thrilling. So if you want more violence, more bits of people being chopped into pieces. Don't go away. I'm David McCloskey, former CIA analyst turned spy novelist. And I'm Gordon Carrera, national security journalist. And together we're the hosts of The Rest is Classified, where we bring you brilliant stories from the world of spies. This week, we're talking about one of the most significant
惊心动魄。所以如果你想要更多的暴力，更多被人砍成碎片的画面。请不要离开。我是大卫·麦克洛斯基，曾任中情局分析师，现为间谍小说家。我是戈登·卡雷拉，国家安全记者。我们一起主持《间谍真相》，为您带来间谍世界的精彩故事。本世纪最重大的故事之一
stories of the 21st century, Edward Snowden, and how he orchestrated the biggest leak of classified secrets in modern American and British history. Snowden revealed that the American government was mass collecting data on its own citizens and it was really the first time that Americans and so many others around the world understood the extent of the US government's mass surveillance. That's right, it's a story I covered at the time. And it really gets to wider questions about what privacy means, how technology has changed our lives, and what the government and companies can do with data we might have thought was private. And we'll take you through the whole story
爱德华·斯诺登，以及他如何策划了现代美英历史上最大规模的机密泄露事件。斯诺登揭露了美国政府在其自身公民身上大规模收集数据，这真的是美国人以及世界各地许多其他人第一次了解美国政府大规模监控的程度。没错，这是我当时报道过的一个故事。它真正触及了更广泛的问题，即隐私意味着什么，技术如何改变了我们的生活，以及政府和公司可以对我们原本认为是隐私的数据做些什么。我们将带您了解整个故事
from Snowden's early career in the CIA and the NSA to his life in exile in Russia. So to hear more search for The Rest is Classified wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to The Rest is History. Dominic is all kicking off in Moscow, in the Kremlin. We are May 1682, the Streltsy, these guys in yellow boots, caftans, furry hats, have stormed theremlin. And they're basically chopping people that they don't like into little pieces. And inside the, the palace of facets in the Kremlin, poor little Peter, only 10 years old with his mother, with his half brother, Ivan, they are huddled in a corner and they must be kind of worrying whether they might be joining the dismembered body parts out in the court.
从斯诺登早年在中情局和国安局的职业生涯到他在俄罗斯的流亡生活。想听更多内容，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《间谍真相》。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。多米尼克，莫斯科的克里姆林宫里一切都在爆发。现在是1682年5月，斯特列利齐——这些穿着黄色靴子、长袍、皮帽的家伙——已经冲进了克里姆林宫。他们基本上把他们不喜欢的人砍成小块。在克里姆林宫的刻面宫内，可怜的小彼得只有10岁，和他的母亲、同母异父的哥哥伊万一起，缩在一个角落里，他们一定在担心自己是否会加入外面庭院里的残肢断臂中。
Of course, because the Streltsy have kind of gone for a rest, but the next morning they come back for more. So Natalia and Peter and Ivan are still sort of in this corner kind of crying and whatever. They've had a sleepless night, terrified that they're going to be thrown into pike points as well. The Streltsy return, they say to Natalia, well, there are probably loads of your relatives still here and we're going to kill them too. And they have a particular hatred of her brother, who's also called Ivan, confusingly. And they basically say, we're not going to give up until we've found him, we've chopped him into pieces too. And so for the next two days, they're all trapped in the palace while the Streltsy are
当然，因为斯特列利齐已经去休息了，但第二天早上他们又回来索命了。所以娜塔莉亚、彼得和伊万仍然呆在这个角落里哭泣什么的。他们度过了一个不眠之夜，惊恐万状地担心自己也会被扔到长矛尖上。斯特列利齐回来了，他们对娜塔莉亚说，好吧，这里可能还有你的很多亲戚，我们也要杀了他们。他们对她的哥哥有着特别的仇恨，很不巧他也叫伊万。他们基本上说，不找到他我们决不罢休，要把他也碎尸万段。所以在接下来的两天里，他们都被困在宫殿里，而斯特列利齐则
just searching like drawers, cellars, behind the wardrobe, under the bed, looking for Natalia's brother. And eventually the Streltsy say, oh, this is ridiculous now. This is massively out of hand. Look, if you don't give up your brother, we will kill everybody. We will literally kill everybody in the palace, including the royal family. And Sophia, who's sort of been behind all this, but it's hanging around the sister who sang hanging around as well.
像搜查抽屉、地窖、衣柜后、床底下一样，四处搜寻娜塔莉亚的哥哥。最后斯特列利齐说，哦，这太荒谬了。这完全失控了。听着，如果你不交出你哥哥，我们就杀光所有人。我们字面意义上会杀光宫殿里的所有人，包括皇室成员。索菲亚一直在幕后操纵这一切，但也一直在附近闲逛，作为姐姐她也在附近闲逛。
She goes up to Natalia in front of everybody and she says, your brother will not, will not escape the Streltsy. There is no way out to save our lives. You must give up your brother." And poor Natalia, she's in floods of tears. And she basically says to her servants, go and get him. And they dig him out from whatever kind of cupboard he's been hiding in. He'd hidden in the cupboard hadn't he? And they'd left the door open. So it looked like they'd already searched it.
她在所有人面前走到娜塔莉亚面前说，你的哥哥绝对、绝对逃不过斯特列利齐的手掌心。为了保全我们的性命，别无出路。你必须交出你的哥哥。可怜的娜塔莉亚泪如泉涌。她基本上对她的仆人们说：去把他找出来。他们把他从他一直藏着的某种橱柜里挖了出来。他藏在橱柜里，不是吗？他们把门开着。所以看起来他们已经搜过了。
That's it. Very clever. Yeah. So she takes him into the palace chapel. He's given communion for the last time. She gives him an icon of the Virgin to hold. And then she leads him outside. And maybe, you know, if this was a film, there'd be a lovely twist now where the Streltsy actually, they're moved by this scene and the sight of him with his icon.
就是这样。非常聪明。是的。所以她把他带进宫殿的小礼拜堂。他最后一次接受了圣餐。她递给他一个圣母像拿着。然后她把他带到外面。也许，你知道，如果这是一部电影，现在会有一个精彩的转折，斯特列利齐实际上被这个场景以及他拿着圣像的样子感动了。
But they're not. They drag him out into Red Square. They torture him. Yeah, because they break his wrists and ankles, don't they, so that they kind of hang it flopping. Yeah, it's a dreadful scene. They do this weird thing where they lift his body up on their spear points and kind of parade him around. And then they just cut him up and then they stamp on all the pieces, which just seems
但他们没有。他们把他拖到红场。他们折磨他。是的，因为他们折断了他的手腕和脚踝，不是吗，好让他挂着无力地下垂。是的，这是一个可怕的场景。他们做了一件奇怪的事情，把他的尸体举在长矛尖上游街示众。然后他们把他砍碎，接着践踏所有的碎片，这简直
unnecessary, I think. I think it's, I would call that, that's robust even by Russian standards, isn't it? Yeah. I think it's fair to say the Streltsy's methods are a little bit unsound. Would you agree with that Tom? I think I would. So anyway, they've completely won. They end up being appointed as the palace guard. The Kremlin's silver is all melted down to give the Streltsy ten rubles each. So there's the Caesar's policy. Yeah, but too late, but too late, right?
是多此一举，我想。我认为这……即便以俄罗斯的标准来看，这也是极其粗暴的，不是吗？是的。我认为公平地说，斯特列利齐的方法有点不太健全。你同意这一点吗，汤姆？我想我是同意的。总之，他们完全胜利了。他们最终被任命为宫廷卫队。克里姆林宫的白银全部被熔化，分给每个斯特列利齐十卢布。这就是恺撒的政策。对，但是太晚了，但太晚了，对吧？
They're given a triumphal column in Red Square in which the names of all the people they've killed are inscribed as common criminals. So Peter is not actually deposed, but Sophia gets her way so that her brother, Ivan, is raised to joint Tsar and is going to be listed first and she will be the regent instead of Natalia. But Natalia is fine, isn't she? Yeah, she's not executed or anything like that. So there's a coronation two weeks later, joint coronation of Peter and Ivan, and this gives
他们在红场获得了一座凯旋柱，他们杀害的所有人的名字都被作为普通罪犯刻在上面。所以彼得实际上并没有被废黜，但索菲亚达到了目的，她的弟弟伊万被推举为共同沙皇，并将名列首位，而她将代替娜塔莉亚担任摄政王。但娜塔莉亚很好，不是吗？是的，她没有被处决或诸如此类的事。所以在两周后举行了加冕礼，彼得和伊万的联合加冕，这给
you a sort of sense of Russia's culture at the time. So they are crowned with a thing called the Golden Cap of Monomakh, which is a sort of skull cap ornamented with gold and pearls and trimmed with fur. It's got a golden cross on the top. And the story, legend has it that this was presented to Vladimir II of Kiev by the emperor Constantine IX Monomachus. And this is obviously, I mean, this is actually nonsense. It probably wasn't, but the claim is that this is the incarnation of Moscow's role as the third Rome, that this is a kind of symbol
你一种当时俄罗斯文化的感受。所以他们戴着用一种叫做莫诺马赫金帽的东西加冕，这是一种用黄金和珍珠装饰、边缘有皮毛饰边的无边小帽。顶部有一个金十字架。故事，传说这是基辅的弗拉基米尔二世由皇帝君士坦丁九世·莫诺马赫赠送的。这显然——我的意思是，这实际上是无稽之谈。它可能不是，但声称这是莫斯科作为第三罗马角色的化身，这是一种
of its lineage, I guess. But interestingly, this is the last time that cap, which still exists, this is the last time that cap, which still exists, this is the last time that cap is ever used to crown a czar because for Peter, this whole business has been so traumatic and so defining. He's seen about 40 of his relatives slaughtered in the most horrendous circumstances. And he, even as he's being crowned, I think he's burning with this tremendous hatred of the Streltsy, but also of what they represent, which is precisely this, Russia's
血统的象征，我猜。但有趣的是，这是那顶至今仍然存在的帽子最后一次被使用，这是那顶至今仍然存在的帽子最后一次被使用，这是那顶至今仍然存在的帽子最后一次被使用来为沙皇加冕，因为对彼得来说，整件事情是如此具有创伤性和决定性。他目睹了大约40位亲人在最可怕的环境中被屠杀。而且他，甚至在加冕时，我想他内心也燃烧着对斯特列利齐的巨大仇恨，同时也对他们所代表的东西充满仇恨，这正是俄罗斯的
medieval past, its heritage from Constantinople, what he sees as its kind of barbarism and superstition. So kind of icons with candle wax dripping down them and all of that. A golden icon kind of glimmering in the murk with smoke from candles in front of it and men with gigantic beards chanting. This which a lot of people find very attractive about Russian culture and is part of the sort of slightly orientalist fantasy of Russia, Peter despises this. He says actually reality.
中世纪过去、它从君士坦丁堡继承的遗产、他所认为的那种野蛮和迷信。比如滴着蜡烛油的圣像以及所有这些。金色的圣像在昏暗中隐隐闪烁，前面点着蜡烛的烟雾，留着巨大胡须的男人们在吟唱。许多人觉得俄罗斯文化非常有吸引力，这是俄罗斯某种东方主义幻想的一部分，而彼得对此嗤之以鼻。他说实际上现实。
Well I think fair enough to be honest. Yeah, because just off camera are a load of blokes with pikes chopping my relatives into pieces. Jumping up on their kind of body parts. Exactly. So I think this is the world that he is determined to destroy. And this becomes a defining feature in his life because he's had this, you know, this horrendously upsetting experience when he was just 10 years old anyway so he he's slightly out of the picture because Sophia is now the the mistress I think you could say of Of Russia now, unfortunately, we we have only really one
嗯，老实说我觉得情有可原。是的，因为镜头之外是一堆拿着长矛把我的亲戚砍成碎片的家伙。跳到他们的尸体块上。完全正确。所以我想这就是他决心要摧毁的世界。这成为他生活中的一个决定性特征，因为他有过（你知道的）这种极其痛苦的经历，当时他才10岁，无论如何，他有点淡出了人们的视线，因为索菲亚现在是——我想你可以说是——俄罗斯的主人了。不幸的是，我们实际上只有一个人
description of her and it came from the French envoy and he wrote an unbelievably of her and it came from the French envoy and he wrote an unbelievably, I don't think you could get away with this now. It's not Galan. It's not at all. He really lets France's traditions of chivalry down. So Theo, close your ears. He wrote, her mind and her great ability bear no relation to the deformity of her person as she is immensely fat with a head as large as a bushel, hairs
对她的描述，来自法国特使，他写了一段令人难以置信的关于她的描述，来自法国特使，他写了一段令人难以置信的，我想你现在绝对没法这么说。这可不怎么高尚。一点也不。他真的让法国的骑士精神传统扫地了。索菲亚，闭上你的耳朵。他写道：她的心智和杰出的能力与她身体的畸形完全不成比例，她胖得惊人，头大如斗，头发
on her face and tumours on her legs. But he then said, in the same degree that her stature is broad, short and coarse, her mind is shrewd, subtle, unprejudiced and full of policy. So she is an impressive person. Peter himself later says that she's physically very pre-possessing. I mean, this is kind of years on. And also, I mean, maybe the very fact that is the only description of her implies that actually, she can't have been that repulsive, or others would have commented on it.
长在脸上，腿上有肿瘤。但他接着说：与她那宽阔、矮小、粗俗的身材成正比的，是她精明、狡猾、毫无偏见且充满政治手腕的心智。所以她是一个令人印象深刻的人。彼得本人后来也说她外表非常迷人。我的意思是，这已经是多年以后了。而且，我的意思是，也许关于她的唯一的描述这一事实本身就暗示了，实际上，她不可能那么令人反感，否则其他人也会对它发表评论了。
I like the fact that you're defending Sophia's... Well, I quite like her. Yeah, I do too. I think she's very impressive. She's a figure of some glamour. So she has two very impressive lieutenants. She has a new Streltsy commander, who's a guy called Shacklovity, and her chief ally is a man called Prince Vasily Vasilyevich Golitsyn.
我喜欢你为索菲亚辩护……嗯，我挺喜欢她的。是的，我也挺喜欢。我觉得她非常了不起。她是一个很有魅力的人物。所以她有两个非常了不起的副手。她有一个新的斯特列利齐指挥官，一个叫什克洛维季的家伙，她最主要的盟友是一个叫瓦西里·瓦西里耶维奇·戈利岑亲王的人。
So the Golitsyns are one of Russia's most prominent noble families, and this guy, Golitsyn, becomes her chief minister. And he later on becomes one of Peter's great antagonists. And yet, Golitsyn as well is a kind of Westernizer. So he's fluent in Latin and Greek. His, his palace in, in Moscow is full of kind of Western artworks and German maps and Venetian mirrors and things. He's a huge admirer of Louis the 14th.
所以戈利岑家族是俄罗斯最显赫的贵族家庭之一，而这个叫戈利岑的家伙成了她的首席大臣。他后来成了彼得的伟大对头之一。然而，戈利岑也是一个西化派。所以他精通拉丁语和希腊语。他在莫斯科的宫殿里到处都是西方艺术品、德国地图、威尼斯镜子之类东西。他是路易十四的超级崇拜者。
He's sort of saying, Oh, we should really, you know, we should really modernize ourselves, we should have religious tolerance. We could emancipate the serfs. We could have a new army, all of this kind of stuff. And so actually, he and Sophia, who are the kind of villains in the Peter the Great story, they run Russia really well for the next kind of decade or so. And it's mad, isn't it, that a woman is in a position of power in Russia when you think of how institutionally
他有点像在说，哦，我们真的应该（你知道的），我们真的应该让我们自己现代化，我们应该有宗教宽容。我们可以解放农奴。我们可以拥有一支新军队，所有诸如此类的事情。所以实际上，他和索菲亚——在彼得大帝的故事里他们有点像是反派——在接下来的十年左右里把俄罗斯治理得非常好。这太疯狂了，不是吗？当你想到俄罗斯在体制上是多么地
and culturally sexist it is? Yeah, it's well, it's mad and it's a massive tribute to her political deafness, isn't it? To her dexterity, because actually Russia is in the next few years is quite quiet. Galitsyn, however, he gets sort of trapped by foreign policy. His big achievement is he negotiates a treaty with the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth after years of war that gives Russia a lot of territory, including Smolensk and Kiev and Eastern Ukraine. So that's the first time that Muscovy gets its hands on Kiev. Exactly, exactly.
和文化上是多么地重男轻女时，一个女人竟然能在俄罗斯掌权？是的，这……嗯，这太疯狂了，这是对她政治精明程度的巨大致敬，不是吗？对她的灵活性，因为实际上俄罗斯在接下来的几年里相当平静。然而，戈利岑却被外交政策给套牢了。他最大的成就是在多年的战争之后与波兰立陶宛联邦谈判达成了一项条约，为俄罗斯赢得了大量领土，包括斯摩棱斯克、基辅和乌克兰东部。所以那是莫斯科公国第一次把手伸向基辅。精确，精确。
But the price for this treaty is the polls say, well, you have to join in with us and our allies who are the Habsburgs and Venice fighting the Ottomans. That's the price. And Gillit said, well, fine. I mean, I don't really want to fight the Ottomans, but we will, we'll attack the carnate of Crimea because, you know, that's an Ottoman vassal and that's kind of doable. And as we will see, this becomes a decisive moment in the story of Sophia and Galitzin. And meanwhile, before we come to what happened about that, let's look at what's been going on with Peter.
但这项条约的代价是，波兰人说，好吧，你必须加入我们以及我们的盟友——哈布斯堡王朝和威尼斯——与奥斯曼帝国的战斗。这就是代价。戈利岑说，好吧。我的意思是，我其实不想跟奥斯曼帝国打仗，但我们会打的，我们会攻击克里姆林汗国，因为（你知道的）那是奥斯曼帝国的附庸，而且这还算行得通。正如我们将看到的，这成了索菲亚和戈利岑故事中的一个决定性时刻。与此同时，在我们探讨这件事的结局之前，让我们看看彼得那边一直在发生什么。
So Peter's only 10 years old. He is kind of just a figurehead. He's always been dragged out for banquets and things to meet ambassadors. And the ambassadors write reports of him. They always say, oh, he's a very likable lad. He has a frank and open face, his great beauty in his lively manner, his half laughing mouth, he's a remarkably good looking boy, all this kind of thing. This is, these are kind of quotes from German doctors and Swedish diplomats and things. So people say, you know, he's very impressive. One day he'll be a good czar. The good news for him is basically he can spend a lot of his time
所以彼得当时只有10岁。他基本上只是一个傀儡。他总是被拉出来参加宴会之类的事情，去见大使。大使们写了关于他的报告。他们总是说，哦，他是个非常讨人喜欢的男孩。他有着坦率开放的面孔，他那活泼的举止中带着极大的美感，他半笑的嘴唇，他是一个非常好看的男孩，所有诸如此类的事情。这些是来自德国医生、瑞典外交官之类的引言。所以人们说（你知道的），他非常了不起。总有一天他会成为一个好沙皇。对他的好消息是，基本上他可以花大量时间
actually hanging out with his mum. They go to this. His father had a, had had a hunting lodge at a place called Priobrzańskie. Where? Priobrzańskieanskaya Tom have you do you want to have a go so he's hanging around on this on this country estate and this is the point at which he gets into one of his great passions which is kind of bonkers war games well because he can i mean he's not just playing with toy soldiers is he he ends up playing with real soldiers and real artillery and all kinds of stuff. Yeah. I mean, he has been obsessed with war since he was a boy. He has always had sort of play soldiers. Yeah. His friends were chosen for him from other noble families and boyar families. And he basically, when he goes to this hunting lodge, he rounded up all his dad's old servants, the kind of fulconers and the kind of hangers
实际上和他的妈妈在一起。他们去这个地方。他的父亲在一个叫普里奥布拉任斯科耶的地方有一个狩猎小屋。哪儿？普里奥布拉任斯科耶，汤姆，你想试试吗？所以他在这个乡间庄园里闲逛，这就是他迷上他的伟大激情之一的时刻，也就是那种疯狂的战争游戏，因为他可以——我的意思是，他不仅在玩玩具士兵，对吧？他最后竟然开始和真正的士兵、真正的火炮以及各种各样的东西一起玩了。是的。我的意思是，他从小就痴迷于战争。他一直都有某种玩具士兵。是的。他的朋友们是从其他贵族家庭和波雅尔家庭中为他挑选的。基本上，当他去这个狩猎小屋时，他把父亲所有的老仆人——那种养鹰人和
on at the hunting lodge. And he said, you know, I'm going to make you an army. And by the time he's in his sort of mid teens, the word has spread around the area that the czar, because he is kind of still joint czar, he wants people to join his kind of play army. And so loads of young men turn up at this estate, some from noble families, some who are serfs, some who are grooms, all of this kind of thing. If you're 20 years old and you want a bit of a laugh, you turn up at this place because also of course, it ingratiates you of course with the, with the Tsar. And the outfit that they're being given, these kind of play
狩猎小屋里的闲杂人等——都召集起来。他说，你知道的，我要组建一支军队。当他十几岁的时候，这个消息在这个地区传开了，说沙皇（因为他某种程度上仍然是联合沙皇）想要人们加入他的某种游戏军队。于是大批年轻人来到这个庄园，有些来自贵族家庭，有些是农奴，有些是马夫，所有诸如此类的事情。如果你20岁，想找点乐子，你就会来到这个地方，因为当然，这也会让你讨好沙皇。而且他们得到的这套行头，这些所谓的
soldiers are Western outfits, right? Yes. They're not the kind of kaftans and yellow boots. It's tricorn hats and... Right, and a big green coat, like a green coat and a kind of tricorn hat, exactly. And there's about 300 of them. They live in, he says, well, I'll build you a barracks. So they're given ranks, they're given a soldier's pay. So in the long run, these two regiments evolve into the Praerbryzhensky and Semyonovsky Guards regiments, which become the oldest regiments in the Russian army.
玩具士兵是西式的，对吧？是的。他们不是那种长袍和黄色靴子。是三角帽和……对，还有一件大绿大衣，就像一件绿大衣和一种三角帽，完全没错。大约有300人。他们住在……他说，好吧，我给你们建个军营。所以他们被授予军衔，他们得到了士兵的薪水。从长远来看，这两个团演变成了普里奥布拉任斯科耶近卫军和谢苗诺夫斯基近卫军，它们成为了俄罗斯军队中最古老的团。
And they were only disbanded, Tom, after the Russian Revolution. So there you go. Such vandalism. So basically, they spend all their time like digging trenches, playing war games, and Peter joins in, but he insists, and this is a defining thing about him. He says, I'm not going to be a commander. I'll just be a common soldier. He loves this kind of play acting, this role playing.
汤姆，它们直到俄国革命后才被解散。所以你看。真是肆意的破坏。所以基本上，他们把所有时间都花在挖战壕、玩战争游戏上，彼得也加入了进来，但他坚持——这是他的一大决定性特征。他说：我不会当指挥官。我只当一个普通士兵。他喜欢这种角色扮演。
So he says, I'm a drummer boy. And every now and again, he gives himself a promotion. So he advances slowly up the ranks. It's a bombardier, doesn't he? It becomes a bombardier, but they do really matter. I mean, when we say they're kind of play soldiers, they spent a whole year building a fort and then they held a siege, attacking it with cannons. And Peter playing on his drum.
所以他说：我是个鼓手男孩。每隔一段时间，他就会给自己升职。他慢慢地在军衔中晋升。他成了炮手，不是吗？他成了一名炮手，但他们真的很重要。我的意思是，当我们说他们是某种玩具士兵时，他们花了一整年时间建造了一座堡垒，然后进行了一场围攻，用大农炮攻击它。而彼得则在打鼓。
Yeah. Can I just ask that thing of Peter not promoting himself over the heads of people who might be better qualified than him. Yeah. Is he also kind of making a political statement there, looking ahead that birth won't necessarily guarantee privileged position, do you think? I think he is. I think it definitely has a political meaning. I think there's no way in a society that is so conservative and so hierarchical as 17th century Muscovy or Russia,
是的。我能问一下彼得不把自己晋升到那些可能比他更有资格的人头上这件事吗？是的。他是否也是在某种程度上发表政治声明，展望未来，即出身并不能保证特权地位，你觉得呢？我想他是的。我认为这绝对具有政治意义。我认为在17世纪莫斯科公国或俄罗斯这样一个极其保守和等级森严的社会里，
there is no way that could not have a kind of political significance. Because it's kind of instilling a notion that meritocracy will matter under his rule. And as we'll see, he does this in very peculiar ways in other forms, like he sets up his own kind of mock church, doesn't he? In his own mock court. And all of this stuff that is, this is when they're doing the sort of dwarf tossing and like playing terrible practical jokes on people with bellows and stuff like this. Bears. Yeah, but all this sort of strange role playing runs all the way through his life. Like when he
这绝不可能没有某种政治意义。因为这灌输了一种观念，即在他的统治下精英统治将发挥作用。正如我们将看到的，他在其他形式中以非常奇特的方式做到了这一点，比如他建立了自己的某种模仿教堂，不是吗？在他自己的模仿法庭里。所有这些东西，就是他们玩抛侏儒以及对人用风箱之类的恶作剧的时候。熊。是的，但所有这种奇怪的角色扮演贯穿了他的一生。比如当他
goes in disguise, sort of incognito to Holland or to England, he's always- But it's very subversive, isn't it? Yeah. In a society where the status of the Tsar is conveyed through what he wears and the postures that he takes, to subvert it so profoundly is in effect to subvert a lot of the ideology that is governing his monarchy. That's right, although the funny thing is he subverted kind of only so far. Up to a certain point.
伪装成化名潜入荷兰或英国时，他总是——但这不是很颠覆吗？是的。在一个以沙皇的穿着和姿态来传达其地位的社会里，如此深刻地颠覆它，实际上就是颠覆了统治他君主制的很多意识形态。没错，尽管有趣的是，他只是在一定程度上进行了颠覆。在某种程度上。
Yeah, because if you really did treat him with no deference, I mean, he, he would kill you personally, but had you or something. So he's recalibrating what it is to be as are. I mean, he's not abdicating his, his, uh, absolute rule, but he wants to reconfigure it. Yeah. I think that's absolutely right. I think that's right. And I think what's remarkable about him, it's not just the role playing. It's also his enthusiasm, his tremendous energy and his curiosity. You know, he has insatiable appetite for learning things and for doing things. And it's practical things as well, isn't it? So it's not just kind of learning about the
是的，因为如果你真的对他毫无敬意，我的意思是，他会亲自杀了你，或者别的什么。所以他正在重新校准作为沙皇意味着什么。我的意思是，他并没有放弃他的绝对统治，但他想要重新配置它。是的。我认为这完全正确。我认为这是对的。而且我认为他引人注目的地方不仅仅是角色扮演。还有他的热情、他巨大的精力和好奇心。你知道，他对学习事物和做事有着取之不竭的胃口。而且这也是非常实际的事情，对吧？所以不仅是了解
broad sweep of the world, but it's about how do you make things? Right. So he does things like when he's a teenager, when he was not sort of attacking fake forts and stuff, he has a big sort of clock, like a grandfather clock, ordered and brought so he can take it apart and put it back together. He has a carpenter's bench. He's the kind of boy who, you know, he said, what do you want for Christmas? He'd say a lathe. He loves a lathe. He's always messing around with lathes and stonemasons tools. He learns to carve ivory. He learns to turn wood. He basically does a lot of things that I would hate to do because I have no interest in lathes, I'll just put it out there, but his biggest passion.
世界的宏大面貌，而且是关于如何制造东西？对。所以他做的事情就像他十几岁的时候，当他没有在攻击假堡垒之类的东西时，他订购并运来了一个大型的时钟，比如一个祖父钟，这样他就可以把它拆开再组装起来。他有一个木工工作台。他是那种（你知道的）你会问他圣诞节想要什么，他会说想要一台车床的孩子。他喜欢车床。他总是摆弄车床和石匠工具。他学会了雕刻象牙。他学会了车木头。他基本上做了很多我讨厌做的事情，因为我对车床毫无兴趣，我就直说了吧，但他最大的激情
Is the sea and ships. So in 1688, when he's what 16, somebody gave him a sextant, but nobody knew what it was or how to use it. And they said, Oh, there's some bloke in the German suburb. He's a Dutchman. He's called Franz Timmerman. He smokes a pipe. He could, he'll, he'll show you this boat Timmerman turns up and he says, I'll
是大海和船只。所以在1688年，他16岁的时候，有人送了他一个六分仪，但没有人知道它是什么或者怎么使用它。他们说，哦，德国人聚居区里有个家伙。他是个荷兰人。他叫弗兰斯·蒂默曼。他抽着烟斗。他可以，他会，他会给你看这个……蒂默曼出现了，他说，我来
show you how to use the sextant. And he ends up teaching Peter geometry and geography, and they go for these long walks together talking about geography. And one of these walks that summer, they're in this state and they, they find this shed full of junk and they go into the shed, what's all this? And they find a boat upside down. And Dominic, where has that boat come from? Do you know where it's come from?
教你怎么用六分仪。他最后教彼得几何和地理，他们一起进行这些漫长的散步，谈论地理。在那年夏天的其中一次散步中，他们在庄园里，他们发现了一个满是破烂的棚子，他们走进棚子里，这都是些什么？他们发现了一艘倒扣着的船。多米尼克，那艘船是从哪里来的？你知道它是从哪里来的吗？
It's come from our own country. It's come from England. It's an English boat. It's got masts and it's got sails and it can go against the wind. This is what Timmerman tells Peter. He says, look, if we sort this out, you could go sailing on this and you, you know, it'd be amazing. And Peter, Oh, brilliant. He says, could you know anyone who can, um, who can fix it? Timmer says, want to know another Dutchman called Karsten Brandt? He could repair it. Peter says, brilliant. They get this bloke
它来自我们自己的国家。它来自英国。它是一艘英国船。它有桅杆，有风帆，还能逆风航行。这就是蒂默曼告诉彼得的。他说，听着，如果我们把这个修好，你可以乘这个去航行，而且（你知道的）这会很棒。彼得说，哦，太棒了。他说，你认识谁能，嗯，谁能修好它吗？蒂默曼说，想认识另一个叫卡斯滕·勃兰特的荷兰人吗？他可以修理它。彼得说，太棒了。他们让这个家伙
brand to do this. They get this boat, they take it to the river. And then he goes sailing every single day. And do you know, that boat is in the Naval Museum in St. Petersburg to this day. The boat is called the grandfather of the Russian Navy. And it's an English boat. I love it. Now the Russians have never been interested in the sea. They're a landlocked country. Because as we said, there's only Archangel. No Baltic, no Black Sea. So everybody says, what's going on here? What's all this business? They're baffled by it.
勃兰特来做这件事。他们弄到了这艘船，把它带到了河边。然后他每天都去航海。你知道吗，那艘船至今仍陈列在圣彼得堡的海军博物馆里。那艘船被称为俄罗斯海军的祖父。它是一艘英国船。我太喜欢了。现在俄罗斯人从来对大海不感兴趣。他们是一个内陆国家。正如我们所说，只有阿尔汉格尔斯克。没有波罗的海，没有黑海。所以每个人都说，这到底是怎么回事？这都是些什么生意？他们对此感到困惑。
But Peter basically gets permission to go to a lake. He builds a boatyard on this lake. He says to this bloke Brant, this Dutchman, build me more, build more ships. And they start building frigates and yachts and all this kind of thing. And I don't think you have to be a tremendous amateur psychologist to work out that actually this is about Peter's. He dreams of escaping the suffocating, claustrophobic atmosphere of Moscow and of the Kremlin and the sea, the salt, you know, the breeze, all of that stuff.
但彼得基本上获得了去一个湖泊的许可。他在这个湖上建立了一个造船厂。他对这个叫勃兰特的荷兰人说，为我建造更多船只，建造更多的船。他们开始建造护卫舰、游艇和所有诸如此类的事情。我想你不需要成为一个伟大的业余心理学家就能看出，实际上这关乎彼得的内心。他梦想着逃离莫斯科和克里姆林宫那令人窒息、幽闭恐怖的氛围，而大海、盐分（你知道的）微风，所有这些东西。
That's his dream. Presumably the fact that his accomplices in this are both Dutch and that the ship is English. It means specifically that he's looking westwards. And it's around this time, isn't it, that he starts signing his name Petrus, so the Latin form of Peter. And of course, he's learning Dutch from speaking to these Dutchmen. So he is starting to look westwards in a way that no Russian leader had ever done before and a lot of people are very concerned about this and actually his mother among them, she says, what's he doing spent hanging around with all these Dutchmen and boats, he needs a good Russian wife.
这就是他的梦想。据推测，他在这一过程中的同谋都是荷兰人，而且这艘船是英国的，这一事实意味着他明确地在向西方张望。正是在这个时候，不是吗，他开始用Petrus（彼得的拉丁语形式）来签署他的名字。当然，他在与这些荷兰人的交谈中学习荷兰语。所以他开始以任何俄罗斯领导人从未有过的方式向西方张望，许多人对此非常担忧，实际上他的母亲也在其中，她说，他花时间和所有这些荷兰人和船只混在一起到底在干什么，他需要一个好的俄罗斯妻子。
And so she gets, they have a kind of one of these bride shows. They assemble the candidates at the Kremlin. She picks one for him. He does. He says, I don't care who you pick. I'm not interested. And she picks this 20 year old girl called Eudokia Lopukina. Who's from a kind of conservative Moscow family.
于是她得到了，他们举办了一种新娘秀。他们在克里姆林宫聚集了候选人。她为他挑选了一个。他却说：我不在乎你选谁。我对这不感兴趣。她挑选了这个20岁的女孩，名叫叶多基娅·洛普欣娜。她来自一个保守的莫斯科家庭。
So what's her take on lathes and Dutchman? She hates a lathe. She loathes a Dutchman. She hates a boat. Robert K. Massey describes it as pink, hopeful and helpless, which is very nice. Anyway, she and Peter, they clearly, they clearly do have a relationship of sorts because they ended up having a son Alexis, but they don't really get on at all. When he's awake on his boat, he never writes to her.
那么她对车床和荷兰人的看法是什么？她讨厌车床。她痛恨荷兰人。她讨厌船。罗伯特·K·马西将其描述为粉红、充满希望且无助，这非常不错。总之，她和彼得，他们显然确实有一种某种关系，因为他们最终有了一个儿子阿列克谢，但他们其实一点也合不来。当他在船上醒着时，他从不写信给她。
They have, she has a second son who dies as a baby. Peter doesn't even bother turning up to the funeral. He basically has no real interest in Eudokia at all. And as we shall see, the story does not end very well. Anyway, so he married Eudokia in 1689, January 1689, which is the year he turned 17. And sort of halfway through the year, his mother says, stop messing around with your boat to come back to Moscow. You've got, we've got a chance now to get rid of Sophia and Galitsyn and regain power.
他们有一个作为婴儿夭折的第二个儿子。彼得甚至懒得出席葬礼。他基本上对叶多基娅毫无兴趣。正如我们所看到的，这个故事并没有以很好的方式结束。总之，他在1689年1689年1月娶了叶多基娅，那年他刚好17岁。到了年中左右，他的母亲说：别再摆弄你的船了，快回莫斯科来。你必须，我们现在有机会摆脱索菲亚和戈利岑并重新夺回权力。
And you can take your place as the rightful, unchallenged master of Russia. Because remember we'd said as a price for that deal with the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth, Galitsyn had said, I'll go and have a crack at the Crimea. Well, that went horrendously badly wrong. The first expedition they did in 1687, they didn't even get there. They got halfway through Ukraine and then they basically gave up and went home. The Tatars, who were the kind of the masters of Crimea were always raiding Ukraine. They take loads of prisoners and slaves and stuff.
你能够占据你作为俄罗斯合法、无可争议的主人的地位。因为还记得我们说过，作为与波兰立陶宛联邦达成协议的代价，戈利岑曾说，我要去克里米亚碰碰运气。嗯，那结果糟透了。他们在1687年进行的第一次远征，甚至都没到达那里。他们走到了乌克兰半途，然后基本上就放弃回家了。鞑靼人——克里米亚的主人——经常突袭乌克兰。他们抓走了大量的俘虏和奴隶之类的人。
Very humiliating for the Russians. It's the summer of 1689. Gillitzen had a second go and absolute shambles in a disaster. They got stuck on the isthmus that connects Crimea to kind of mainland Ukraine. And they had to retreat with about 20,000 people killed and 15,000 people taken prisoner. And so Dominic, at this stage, the geography of Russia is working against the Russians because they don't control all of it.
这对俄罗斯人来说非常耻辱。那是1689年的夏天。戈利岑进行了第二次尝试，结果完全是一场混乱和灾难。他们被困在连接克里米亚和乌克兰本土的地峡上。他们不得不撤退，大约2万人被杀，1.5万人被俘。所以多米尼克，在这个阶段，俄罗斯的地理环境对俄罗斯人不利，因为他们并没有控制全部领土。
So the kind of the classic thing, you know, you find yourself marching for days and days across featureless steps. This is happening to them. This is happening to them. Anyway, Galitsyn and his bedraggled kind of remnants get back to Moscow and they declare victory. They say, well, we've won a tremendous victory against the Tatars. You know, delighted with ourselves.
所以那种典型的情况（你知道的），你发现自己在一片毫无特色的草原上行军好几天。这种情况正在发生在他身上。这种情况正在发生。总之，戈利岑和他那衣衫褴褛的残兵败将回到莫斯科，宣布取得胜利。他们说，好吧，我们对鞑靼人取得了巨大的胜利。你知道的，我们为自己感到高兴。
Peter refuses to go to the kind of victory party. He says, this is obviously nonsense. And it's clear that there's a, because he's 17, because he has the kind of play, the pretend army now. Yeah, but how pretend is it? Exactly. There's growing tension and Sophia's allies say to her, in fact, the guy who's the commander of the Streltsy, you've got this guy, Shklovity, he says to Sophia,
彼得拒绝去参加那种庆祝胜利的派对。他说，这显然是无稽之谈。很明显，因为他17岁了，因为他现在有了那支假装的军队。嗯，但它有多假呢？完全没错。紧张局势不断升级，索菲亚的盟友对她说，事实上，斯特列利齐的指挥官——那个叫什克洛维季的家伙——对索菲亚说，
like, if you don't strike against Peter now, you have to kill him now because otherwise he will, he will strike against you, but she hesitates. She doesn't want to lose the moral high ground. he will strike against you. But she hesitates, she doesn't want to lose the moral high ground. And then on the 7th of August, she gets a note, an anonymous note saying that Peter is going to attack you. He's going to attack you with his boy soldiers and kill you. Now no one really knows where this note is from, but she sort of panics and she orders the Streltsy onto kind of full alert. panics and she orders the Streltsy onto kind of full alert. Meanwhile, some of Peter's mates say to him, Sophia is going to strike against you. She's mobilized the Streltsy. So I think what's clearly happened is that people behind the scenes have been stirring
如果你现在不对彼得下手，你必须现在就杀了他，否则他会对你下手，但她犹豫了。她不想失去道德高地。他会对你下手。但她犹豫了，她不想失去道德高地。然后在8月7日，她收到了一封匿名便条，说彼得要攻击你。他要带着他的娃娃兵来攻击并杀死你。现在没有人真正知道这张便条来自哪里，但她有点恐慌，她下令斯特列利齐进入全面戒备状态。恐慌，她下令斯特列利齐进入全面戒备状态。与此同时，彼得的一些朋友对他说，索菲亚要对你下手了。她动员了斯特列利齐。所以我想显然发生的事情是，幕后有人一直在煽动
up trouble and sort of turning the two against each other. And they say, you must flee for your life. So Peter and his friends do flee for their lives and they flee to the most important and the holiest of all Russian monasteries, which is called the Trinity Lavra of St. Sergius. So this is about 40 miles outside Moscow. And he holds up in this monastery with his friends, basically issuing proclamations saying, I'm the Tsar, my sister is sort of, and the Streltsy have been plotting against me. She's saying the same about him. And Dominic, the salient thing about the monastery isn't just that it's very holy, but also that it has a massive walls, right?
麻烦，某种程度上让两人反目成仇。他们说，你必须逃命。于是彼得和他的朋友们为了保命确实逃跑了，他们逃到了俄罗斯最重要、最神圣的修道院，叫做圣谢尔盖三圣修道院。这距离莫斯科大约40英里外。他在这个修道院里和他的朋友们坚守，基本上发表公告说，我是沙皇，我的姐姐是某种，斯特列利齐一直在密谋反对我。她也在说关于他的同样的话。多米尼克，关于这座修道院最突出的地方不仅在于它非常神圣，还在于它拥有巨大的城墙，对吧？
Exactly. You can't storm it. It's effectively impregnable. It's like a fortress. So you have this weird situation all the way through August where Sophia is in the Kremlin, Peter is in this monastery. They're both describing the other one basically as a traitor or are they planning a coup against me, all of this kind of business.
没错。你根本无法攻破它。它实际上是坚不可摧的。它就像一座堡垒。所以在整个八月期间，你都有这样一种奇怪的情况：索菲亚在克里姆林宫，彼得在这个修道院里。他们俩都把对方基本上描述成叛徒，或者他们是在策划反对我的政变吗，所有诸如此类的事情。
And it reminds me a little bit of the, in a sort of much more protracted form of the coup against Mikhail Gorbachev in 1991, where, you know, the coup plotters had seized Moscow, but they weren't very powerful. You know, they weren't, you could see they weren't really up for it. They'd mobilized some of the army, but it was all very uncertain. Hour by hour, if people remember that coup, the momentum was shifting away from them towards Boris Yeltsin. So Peter in this is Yeltsin. So at first you think, oh well, he's fled to the monastery. Sophia's clearly going to win. But actually, because she doesn't manage to move against him over time, momentum moves
这让我想起了一点1991年对米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫的政变，当然那是更持久的形式，当时政变策划者占领了莫斯科，但他们其实并不那么强大。你知道，他们并不是……你能看出他们其实并没有真正准备好。他们动员了部分军队，但一切都非常不确定。如果人们还记得那场政变，就会发现每过一个小时，势头就在从他们那边转向鲍里斯·叶利钦。所以，彼得在这里扮演的就是叶利钦。起初你会想，哦，好吧，他逃到了修道院。索菲娅显然会赢。但实际上，由于她随着时间的推移没能对采取行动，局势开始
more and more towards him. Lots of people are going to the monastery and say, actually, I'm on your side, mate. You know, I'm with you. And is that also reflecting the fact that, of course, fear is a woman? Yes, sure. Whereas Peter is a strapping lad who enjoys playing with soldiers. I'm sure, no doubt at all. So in early September, she decides to break the deadlock.
越来越向他倾斜。许多人前往修道院说，实际上，老兄，我站在你这边。你知道的，我和你在一起。这是否也反映出这样一个事实，即恐惧当然是女性化的？没错，当然。而彼得是一个精力充沛、喜欢和士兵们玩耍的小伙子。毫无疑问，绝对如此。所以在九月初，她决定打破僵局。
She goes off to the monastery. And actually, it's blocked by musketeers, the road. And they say, look, Peter's not going to see you. He doesn't want to see you. You've got to go back to Moscow. She goes back to Moscow. She goes back to the Kremlin. She has a massive meltdown, floods of tears, raging.
她动身前往修道院。实际上，道路被火枪手封锁了。他们说，听着，彼得不会见你的。他不想见你。你得回莫斯科去。她回到了莫斯科。她回到了克里姆林宫。她彻底崩溃了，泪如雨下，大发雷霆。
She says, oh, Peter and his family, the Nurezhkins, they're going to kill us. It's all a disaster, all of this kind of thing. And then eventually, the stalemate, the deadlock is broken, not by Russians, interestingly, but by the foreigners in the German suburb, because the Russian army, the high commander, generally, foreigners, because they're the only people who know what they're doing. And yet again, Tom, it's a man from our own beloved country. It's, um, a Scotsman called general Gordon.
她说，哦，彼得和他的家人娜雷什金家族，他们要杀我们。这一切都是一场灾难，诸如此类的话。然后最终，僵局被打破了，有趣的是，打破僵局的不是俄国人，而是德国人聚居区的外国人，因为俄国军队的高级指挥官通常都是外国人，因为他们是唯一知道自己在做什么的人。汤姆，又一次，这是一个来自我们祖国的人。是个名叫戈登将军的苏格兰人。
It's great to have a general Gordon back on the show. Isn't it? It's been so long. It is. It's a great moment. There's a bloke called general Gordon, but not the general Gordon who got nervous around women, no, no, no, I killed in cartoon. No, not, not, uh, not Chinese Gordon. No, no, no. And got killed in cartoon. Not that one.
能在节目中再次迎来一位戈登将军真是太棒了。不是吗？已经过去好久了。确实。这是一个伟大的时刻。有个家伙叫戈登将军，但不是那个对女人感到紧张的戈登将军，不，不，不，在喀土穆被杀的那个。不，不是，不是中国戈登。不，不，不。而且在喀土穆被杀。不是那一个。
No, not Chinese Gordon. No, this bloke is Russian Gordon. So we'll talk about him in the next episode about his background because he's an interesting character. He is, he's a Scotsman, isn't he, General Gordon? And he has been serving in the Crimea and all this and in these campaigns. He's been torn between the two camps for a long time, but he's very fond of Peter. He'd helped him with his war games.
不，不是中国戈登。不，这家伙是俄国戈登。所以我们将在下一集中谈论他的背景，因为他是一个有趣的人物。是的，他是苏格兰人，对吧，戈登将军？他曾在克里米亚以及这些战役中服役。很长一段时间里，他在两个阵营之间摇摆不定，但他非常喜欢彼得。他曾帮彼得进行军事游戏。
And what makes Gordon's mind up is he says, look, it's clear that actually only one of these people, only one of these camps has real ruthless killer instinct. And you always should back that person, the more ruthless, the more dangerous of the two parties and that is Peter. And so one night he leads all the foreign officers to this monastery, they get there at dawn and one by one, they line up and they kiss Peter's hands. It's like the sort of the Galpacino and the Godfather or something. Yeah.
是什么让戈登下定决心的呢？他说，听着，很明显，实际上只有这些人中的一个，只有这些阵营中的一个才真正拥有冷酷的杀手本能。而你永远应该支持那个人，两者中更冷酷、更危险的一方，那就是彼得。于是有一天晚上，他带领所有的外国军官来到这座修道院，他们在黎明时分到达，一个接一个地排队亲吻彼得的手。这有点像阿尔·帕西诺和《教父》之类的场景。是的。
Very, very Godfather. So the news of this reaches Moscow and the Streltsy in the yellow boots say, Oh, clearly Peter's gonna win. So they change sides as well. And they arrest their own commander, this bloke Shklovity, and he is beheaded Prince Golitsyn, who actually was a very good ruler of Russia and a westernizer, might have been an ally for Peter. He's stripped of all his property property he's exiled to the Arctic and he basically spends the next quarter century of his life 25 years he just lives in the Arctic and no one knows what happened to him that's a terrible
非常、非常的《教父》。所以这个消息传到了莫斯科，穿着黄色靴子的斯特列利齐（射击军）说，哦，很明显彼得要赢了。所以他们也倒戈了。他们逮捕了自己的指挥官，这个叫什克洛维季的家伙，他被斩首了。戈利岑亲王，他实际上是俄国的一位好统治者和西化者，本可能是彼得的盟友。他被剥夺了所有的财产，被流放到了北极，他基本上度过了他生命的最后一个四分之一世纪，即25年，他就住在北极，没有人知道他发生了什么，对于一个喜欢羽管键琴的人来说，这真是一个可怕的
fate for a man who likes a harpsichord isn't it exactly and poor Sophia I mean we're we're quite fond of Sophia aren't we yeah she was exiled to a convent and she lived there for 15 years and was never seen in public again. But I mean, it could have been worse because she's not, I mean, she doesn't have a head shaved. She doesn't get given a kind of new name because she hasn't been made into to become a nun. No, she just has to hang out with nuns, but she has to hang out with nuns, but she has a certain degree of kind of independence.
命运，不是吗？确实。可怜的索菲娅，我的意思是，我们其实挺喜欢索菲娅的，对吧？是的，她被流放到了一座修道院，在那里生活了15年，再也没有在公众面前露面。但我的意思是，情况本可能会更糟，因为她，我的意思是，她的头发没有被剃掉。她没有被赐予一个新名字，因为她没有被强迫成为修女。不，她只是不得不和修女们呆在一起，但她确实有一定的独立性。
A little bit, yeah. For now. For now, for now, because we will see what happens later on. So now Peter, only when she's safely gone to this convent, does Peter ride into Moscow in triumph. And it's an amazing scene. This is kind of the end of your season one of the kind of Apple TV series or whatever. He rides in past lines of Streltsy, kind of kneeling in the dust to ask for his forgiveness. He goes through the gates of the Kremlin. He goes up to the cathedral, to the Dolmishan Cathedral.
有一点，是的。目前是的。目前，目前，因为我们会看看后来会发生什么。所以现在，只有当她安全地离开并进入这座修道院后，彼得才凯旋骑马进入莫斯科。这是一个惊人的场景。这有点像是你的苹果电视剧集第一季的结局，或者诸如此类。他骑马经过排成一行的斯特列利齐，他们跪在尘土中乞求他的宽恕。他穿过克里姆林宫的大门。他走到大教堂，圣母升天大教堂。
His brother Ivan is still there. He's still kind of hanging around and he embraces Ivan and then he goes into the palace. He puts on the robes of state and then he steps out onto the red staircase, the very place where so many people had been butchered when he was 10 years old. He steps out to receive the acclamation of the crowd. So long last, he's 17 years old. He is the master of Russia.
他的哥哥伊凡还在那里。他仍然在那里闲逛，彼得拥抱了伊凡，然后走进了宫殿。他穿上了国家礼服，然后走上红色台阶，就是那个当他10岁时有许多人被屠杀的地方。他走出来接受人群的欢呼。历经漫长等待，他已经17岁了。他是俄罗斯的主人。
His mother is going to serve as regent, but he really wields supreme power. And Tom, in the next episode, we will find out how he intends to use it. Brilliant, Dominic. Thrilling stuff. And as you said, so much to come. So we've got Peter's gap year in Western Europe, going to Holland, going to England. He gets his revenge on the Streltsy. And then in subsequent episodes, we have the Titanic showdown with the Swedes in the Great Northern War and believe me it really is a great war. So Rest is History Club members of course can hear all the episodes in this series right
他的母亲将担任摄政王，但他真正掌握了最高权力。汤姆，在下一集中，我们将发现他打算如何使用这权力。太棒了，多米尼克。令人兴奋的内容。正如你所说的，接下来还有很多精彩内容。所以我们有彼得在西欧的间隔年，去荷兰，去英国。他向斯特列利齐复仇。然后在随后的剧集中，我们在大北方战争中与瑞典人进行了一场史诗般的对决，相信我，这真的是一场伟大的战争。所以《历史的剩余部分》俱乐部成员当然可以立即收听本系列的所有剧集
now and if you're not a member of the Rest is History Club then you know what to do, you can head to therestishistory.com, but either way, we will be back for more Peter the Great themed action. See you then. Bye bye. Bye bye. former CIA analyst turned spy novelist. And I'm Gordon Carrera, a national security journalist. And together we're the hosts of The Rest is Classified, where we bring you brilliant stories from the world of spies. This week we're talking about one of the most significant stories of the 21st century, Edward Snowden, and how he orchestrated the biggest leak of classified secrets in modern American and British history. Snowden revealed that the American government was mass collecting data on its own
现在，如果你还不是《历史的剩余部分》俱乐部的成员，那么你知道该怎么做，你可以前往 therestishistory.com，但无论如何，我们都会回来更多以彼得大帝为主题的精彩内容。到时见。拜拜。拜拜。曾任CIA分析师转行的间谍小说家。我是戈登·卡雷拉，一名国家安全记者。我们一起主持《机密历史》，在这里为您带来来自间谍世界的精彩故事。本周我们将讨论21世纪最重要的故事之一——爱德华·斯诺登，以及他如何策划了现代美英历史上最大规模的机密泄露事件。斯诺登揭露了美国政府正在对其自身的公民进行大规模数据收集
citizens and it was really the first time that Americans and so many others around the world understood the extent of the U.S. government's mass surveillance. That's right, it's a story I covered at the time and it so really gets to wider questions about what privacy means, how technology has changed our lives and what the government and companies can do with data we might have thought was private and we'll take you through the whole story from Snowden's early career in the CIA and the NSA to his life in exile in Russia. So to hear more search for the rest is classified wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是美国以及世界各地许多人第一次真正理解美国政府大规模监控的程度。没错，这是我当时报道的一个故事，它真正触及了更广泛的问题：隐私意味着什么，技术如何改变了我们的生活，以及政府和公司如何处理我们可能认为是私密的数据。我们将带您了解整个故事，从斯诺登早期在中央情报局和国家安全局的职业生涯，到他在俄罗斯流亡的生活。因此，想要了解更多，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《机密历史》。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。